all right
good morning everyone
I'm opening the house finance executive
session on hb1 and hb2 we'll start with
division one which will present their
recommendations to the full committee
division two and division three may not
be familiar with what division one has
been doing as each other division is
working in their own place after each
division presentation
emotion will be made to accept that
report
then it will be open to further
amendments from the committee members
if any member has a prepared amendment
to offer the committee they must do so
today
after all the division presentations at
the end of all votes today please make
the following and I will do that
so we'll begin with division one and
I'll represent uh
I'll recognize
representative leishman and Maguire as
well as their LBA
to to give them a little help if they
need it thank you
thank you Mr chairman and I'm sure we
may need a little help
you can see by the size of our packet
that we had quite a bit of work to do
and we did a lot of work but before I
get started I'd like to recognize the
two people that really made this
successful for us Melissa on my right
and Mike on my left without the two of
them we probably still be somewhere else
instead of before you
Melissa came to us she's new to the
division but you'd never know it she was
incredible did a great job
and then I'd like to turn to the members
of my division
I can tell you that when the speaker
asked me to chair The Division I thought
it was easier when I probably cheered
the last time when we were in the
majority but being in the equals so to
speak minority majority
I thought it might be challenging it
turned out to be not challenging at all
the members were incredible
representative Griffin and I was as far
as the people sitting here today were
the only ones returning
to division one everybody else was new
to division one
and the amount of work that we faced was
uh at times daunting but we got through
it it was very non-partisan I joke with
my members that we had the professor
with us at sitting to my immediate left
he helped get us through all the tough
details and again we'll start out and if
anyone has any questions feel free to go
through the chair and we'll try to
answer them
so Mr chairman I don't know where you'd
like to start the big document here
where we have
some smaller documents it's it's up to
you I guess I leave your choice to you
all right well I should recognize we
have some Replacements with US
Representative Koval replacing
representative whole and as usual
although he's almost a permanent
replacement representing grassy
replacing representative hatch
and
we we missing over here oh
representative McGuire
replacing
represented Bean
thank you for coming
so what we can do is we'll start with a
big packet let's try not to be extremely
detailed but a lot of this is
self-explanatory I hope
but starting with House Bill one
you'll see we have an amendment um
it'll be on page three of your packet
we'll start at that location as
everybody sure where they are or know
where they are
okay good
so uh you'll see the first amendment is
a recommendation to abolish three
positions they're unfunded uh but what
we're gaining here is we're actually
adding two multi-state Auditors uh they
will be out there looking for if you
will tax cheats or whatever in the big
corporate world outside of New Hampshire
so the dras that we could add a few more
people this gives us a positive balance
because they will be out there finding
additional revenue for the state
um
going right along we have
the estimate of unrestricted revenues
the division found itself this is on
page four
I'll try to again if anyone has any
questions just you know put your hands
up it will slow down
uh
so you'll see at the bottom of the page
representative bucco there's a number
that's what we're following okay thanks
um
so the division found itself in kind of
an interesting position back on the 12th
of March we found that we had between
the house bills we were getting and the
governor's budget we're about 145
million dollars where we shouldn't be so
that's why you'll see as we go through
this where there's some Cuts going on to
page
six of your package we have two doit
positions there's a privacy officer an
administrative positions I believe these
were from a bill that representative
Edwards had introduced at some time
just kind of buttoning things up and
bringing some more security to doit
so now we go to house bill
who
so this item get to the right page here
that's page seven
there's an amendment in your package
that
authorizing the Des to seek higher
bonding Authority right now it's been
limited to three you'll see it's up to
30 million that's what we're proposing
there
again if I'm going too fast please sing
out
moving on to page eight
we have an appropriation for PCB
contamination we have a question
representative Edwards representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr Sharon thank you
um representative alishman I I just uh I
was just a little slow on the
interpretation on page six for the doit
Chief privacy officer and and I had two
bills this year that sounded very
similar to one another one was for the a
privacy officer for DHHS and a separate
bill for a security officer for doit
neither of those were privacy officers
for the doit even though they sound
similar and so I'm I'm not opposed to
this I I just you read into the
testimony that this came from one of my
bills and and I don't believe that's
that's accurate
all right I apologize I do remember
there was some discussion about a
privacy officer with your bill so I yeah
probably the assumption that I should
have made that this may have come from
what you had introduced right right and
because on the doit
security officer that was already funded
that was just putting in the statute the
obligations of the security officer the
the money for the Privacy officers and
DHHS come in division three thank you
all right thank you Carol McGuire for a
question
actually it's a comment when we were
talking about
the uh security officer in Edna we the
commissioner of doit mentioned that he
thought having a Chief privacy officer
of the doit was a good idea and he would
consider putting it in the budget
and so this may have been a request from
doit that got in had to be added as an
amendment
that was my recollection to
representative McGuire but hopefully
we've cleared it up
representative erf has a question
I think my question if we're done with
that one I'd like to ask you a question
about section 35 in hb2
which I think he was just getting to if
I'm not mistaken you have page seven
could you just speak to the increase
from three million dollars to 30 million
dollars in that Amendment
so my memory I recall at the Department
of Environmental Services said that
three million dollars really constrains
them and they ask it to be raised to a
30 million for bonding Authority this
was something we did run by the
treasurer at the time and she didn't see
any particular problem with the request
so this is not an appropriation it's a
it's a bonding
it's an author it's a bond authorization
amount right they cannot exceed 30
million dollars thank you
and the treasurer usually advises
there's another very important bill that
will come before the the house and that
will be capital budget which is usually
hb25 and that's always constrained by
six percent of the of the
total budget or total general fund and
education fund budget so they have to
stay below that
they have to stay below that when they
do any borrowing because it affects the
credit rating so I'm sure the treasurer
has spoken to them as well on this same
one thank you in representative McGuire
like to add to it yeah so in the
original House Bill 2
it just simply removed the three million
dollar cap so the cap became unlimited
so we decided that unlimited was not
correct so we we put in this limit
foreign
thank you Mr chairman so next we have
the
PCB contamination
there was a one million dollar sum here
for uh investigating and Remediation of
PCB contamination
moving to Amendment nine
you'll see this was in section 40 and 41
of House Bill 2 and the division felt
that creating the office of regulatory
review and reduction was not needed it
was about a 750 000 request I believe
for this so we took that out that was in
the governor's hb2
so then we moved to page 10
and it won't go as slow as this because
once we get to oplc we'll go through
about 100 pages so
and if any member has a question push a
button so I'll see the red light quicker
than I might see you nodding or waving
so the next one was dealing with
historic housing preservation
we were looking for additional
information on this we did not get it
but there was a bill in the Senate that
has passed I believe it's 231 and the
Senate put it on their table so there is
a like legislation in the senate for
this
also going to page um let's see tax
credit
did that one
so invest New Hampshire
there's been some concern that the
division cut this by 15 million dollars
as I mentioned at the start of this we
had to make some Cuts in order to get
where we should be
I'd like to actually thank
representative Sweeney who added some
language in an amendment to take
developers out of receiving this money
and make it more of a grant to
communities is that how I interpreted
that correctly thanks
so I think it was a good move but we at
least kept 15 million dollars in there
we made it more of a grant program for
communities versus a loan program this
is new money this is a general fund
dollars uh initially all the money that
had been put in to invest New Hampshire
was Federal money so this is a new
general fund request
so we have the affordable housing
which as you'll see we also reduced that
down to 15 million dollars again we
support the
program but we just didn't have the
money to fully fund it at 25 million
dollars
the next item we have is on noted as
page
I just have to consult with my chief
advisor here my page is not beginning to
line up
in the right hand column they they do
yeah 13.
yeah apparently my my numbers there's
been so many sheet changes here but so
uh
going down so we've gotten through uh 11
so on page 12.
yeah look at them call them they do line
up yep
uh we have the Department of Correction
there's a sum of 10 million dollars for
the surveying design completion
preliminary work for a new men's State
Prison
there was a another amount going to 13
where we had an appropriation the
governance budget of 40 million dollars
we
didn't feel it 40 million dollars at
this point could be funded so we would
remove the 40 million dollars from house
bill 2. that was for the second stage of
the design and work for the men's State
Prison
so we've had a lot of discussion on the
parking garage you probably recall there
was house bill 384.
uh which appropriated funds for the
parking garage that has made it through
this Committee in the Full House
the appropriation that the governor put
in was for 15 million dollars so we
removed the 15 million dollars from the
governor's request and
House Bill too
so moving on to page 15 uh
this is the Christa McAuliffe memorial
fund initially this had been completely
removed from House Bill 2 except for the
creation of this new Commission
but with the encouragement of
Representative evil we put a hundred
thousand dollars into the program so we
did find it some hopefully there will be
enough money to get them started
again that original appropriation was
for five hundred thousand dollars
so going to page
16 through 28
uh
this was quite a process for those of
you that have been following this along
this was House Bill
it came out of the Edna committee with a
very strong vote and passed on the house
floor by 282 to 80.
and representative McGuire was very
represented Dan McGuire uh was very
involved with this whole process as a
matter of fact that's where we tagged
him with the professor of the division
because he gave us about an hour and a
half lecture on how this works or should
work so I don't want to take any of his
work away from him so representative
McGuire I know would like to comment on
this one yes thank you so
um House Bill 436
in in the minds of the sponsors writes a
wrong
um that we did in the budget 12 years
ago 12 years ago we had a very tight
budget and we needed money and
um at the time we were sending a lot of
money for retirement to communities and
and sort of to to compensate a little
bit we
reduced retirement benefits in some in
in a couple of different ways both for
group one and but especially for group
two
and in particular for group two which is
police and fire some of which are state
employees and but most of them are
Municipal Employees we
for for employees who were at the time
working but not yet vested
um we reduced the multiplier that goes
into their pensions so if in general a
pension is based on number of years of
service times
um average final compensation times some
particular multiplier and at the time
that multiplier for group two was two
and a half percent
so for the employees who were
working at the time but not yet vested
that became a ladder for some of them it
became 2.4 percent 2.3 percent 2.2
percent 2.1 percent or two percent and
then for for new employees were hired
after that point it is now two percent
so so that's a considerable difference
right if it had been two and a half
percent becomes two percent that's
that's a 20 reduction in a pension okay
um so this bill
restored those for it only affects or
primarily affects those employees who
were at the time working but not yet
vested right there's no change for
employees who had not yet been hired at
that time and no change for those who
were already vested that those those
hadn't have been affected so this bill
House Bill 436 basically for those
employees that that particular group and
I believe it's roughly 1500 employees
both Municipal and state
um this bill House Bill 436 puts them
back on
um having the same retirement plan they
had when they were hired
um
okay
now
um there's one
um we made one change to the bill as it
came to us because
um and it's not quite the same I mean
there's they're detailed changes but but
we made one particular change to the
bill at the suggestion of the sponsors
which was
um there's an overall cap on the
retirement of these this particular set
of employees of a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars a year and in the
original bill that cap was to have been
have an escalator so that the cap would
be raised by one and a quarter percent
per year over time it affects very few
employees but it's an expensive number
and so that that escalation was taken
out of house bill 36 but other than that
this is the same as house bill 36. this
is the most expensive part of our whole
division it's pay for by 25 million
dollars a year over a 10-year period so
this is not just affecting this current
biennium 25 million dollars a year so 50
million dollars in this biennium but the
next four bienniums another 50 million
dollars okay so it's very expensive paid
for by General funds
um there's also a payment
just a little bit extra just to make
sure that
cities and towns are not affected the
the their employer rates are not
affected by this bill now this
particular amendment has a compromise
because we're spending so much money
here over time this all Amendment also
restores the communication Services tax
that's a tax that raises
roughly 56 57 million dollars a year I'm
sorry a biennium 28 point something
million dollars a year and so it's a
match for the expenses in House Bill 436
over time
the governor's budget had eliminated
that particular tax as a as a compromise
this this amendment also sunsets the
interest in dividends tax one biennium
early so
um so the in current law the the
interest in dividends tax is eliminated
on January 1st of 2027 this amendment
eliminates it on January 1st of 2025.
all right so two years earlier than it
would have been otherwise
so the net result of this amendment is
it makes this particular group of group
two employees whole
it
um
it has a funding mechanism namely the
communication tax ongoing to pay for
that expense but it does sunset the
interest in dividends tax two years
early I can explain why that's important
from economic terms if you like it's
something I've talked about to the
various Ways and Means committees over
the years
but that's what this amendment does
representative erf has a question
just by way of clarification
so
in HP 2 this refers to 101 to one
sections 101 to 110 and I did read your
Amendment but I couldn't read it top
bottom
our 101 to 110 deleted in your amendment
in their entirety yes those are the
sections that that remove the
communication Services tax
okay I mean it talks about all kinds of
other things but they're all related to
the communications and services tax yes
because the communication Services tax
has kind of little pieces scattered
throughout law right so you know they're
in a list of taxes
Communications tax so so House Bill 2
originally eliminated that so it had a
lot of sections because it you know
takes the name out of this part takes
the name out of that fire those kind of
things thank you representative walner
has a question followed by
representative Stringham
thank you thank you representative
McGuire
so
the acceleration of eliminating the IND
tax interest and dividends tax have you
done some estimates of how much you
would estimate the um next biennium will
lose because of that decision
we have done a
let's see the analysis that we were able
to put together working with the LBA the
impact on FY 26 is 57 million dollars
FY 28
25 million dollars
I'm sorry did I say 28 I meant to say
27. thanks Melissa
but again again 57 for 26 and 25 for 27.
but the overall impact of this amendment
over the for the next biennium is about
a negative 25 million dollars because of
the restoration of the communication
Services tax
right so those two taxes
um yes the interest in dividends tax
going away is minus
75 to 80 million but the restoration of
communication Services tax is plus 58 or
so million so the net is in the 25
million range
so representative Stringham followed by
representative so in addition to the 85
million in the next biennium we're
looking at about an additional 18
million for the interest in dividends
tax on this this biennium I think that's
correct and the other two
um and I'm just asking you to confirm
that and then second really really the
um
uh the hb-436 provision and the CST
pretty much balance out especially since
CST is anticipated to decline slowly
does that sound about correct
well what uh what we have here again
looking at the fiscal analysis that was
done for uh us concerning 24 and 25
the net gain for this biennial would be
40 million dollars with the restoration
of the communications tax now indeed the
next biennium will have a a hit but as
far as this biennium what we've done by
restoring the communications tax is a
net gain of 40 million dollars
um follow-up follow-up is that just in
isolation by itself right and not not
including the impact of including 436
and the change in the IND tax or are you
offsetting the IND tax and not hb4 no
that's that's in isolation a gain of 40
million dollars for the biennium okay
thank you
representative tulerski for a question
thank you representative walner asked
one question I had my other one was um
the communication tax restoration did
you get
long-term numbers and projections on the
decline of that and what we're looking
at for fiscal year
26 and 27.
we did not we just focused on what we
were doing for this biennium
thank you
representative McGuire would also like
to weigh you know so the communication
tax is a tax on phone calls and text but
not data so it does not some people
think it's only on landlines it's not
it's it's
essentially 100 on land lines but on
cell phones it's partial because some of
your cell phone cost is associated with
data and some is associated with calls
and text and so the reason it's
declining is because first of all more
people are using cell phones unless
they're using landlines but also because
over time the amount of the cost
allocated to a cell phone is lessening
on date on talking and and ex and
increasing on data but it's not going to
you know people still talk on their
phone so
um you know it's declining but slowly
thank you
so I think again just adding a little
more to this particular section this is
a correction of a wrong that was created
back in 2011. I really want to thank the
members of my division for coming up
with I think a very workable solution to
fund this
um
and again for those taking notes we just
got an update from
our folks at retirement that will be
about
1824 people that would be affected by
this legislation
so moving on to page 29 as I promised
earlier we'd make some significant jumps
along the way
this is the
special injury fund is a special fund
that's been around a long time it helps
small employers deal with workman's comp
claims if they're repeated claims so
people are going to work in a claim that
may have occurred at another employer
isn't coming down on that employers
insurance company or that a new employer
we heard from a number of folks
including some small business New
Hampshire Automobile Dealers Association
that it asked us to remove this from
House Bill 2 in which we did
so page 30.
um
natural and cultural resources these
used to be Park funds what we've done
here is this will be funded through
General funds and no longer Park funds I
think we all know our parks are in dire
Financial Straits so the decision was
made to fund this with General funds
versus Park funds and you'll see the
amount there is about eight hundred
thousand a little more than eight
hundred thousand dollars
so this wasn't this was an add-on
representative McGuire yeah so as we
understand it historically this was
funded with General funds it was only
Park funds in the last biennium
so going to 31 this is a very simple
change was requested from the Department
of Agriculture just to move the meetings
to semi-annual versus quarterly and to
allow some more public input at those
particular meetings and no money was
involved in this
so yes representative Deanne McGuire
just laughed in my the next one here so
so
oplc
you probably have heard a little about
this through your emails there were
hundreds of sections that were proposed
in the governor's budget to change
I want to personally thank
representative Carol McGuire I think
she's joined us here today just to make
sure we do what's right with this
um
also when her husband Dan worked very
hard with US representative
groda was very much involved a ranking
member of the Edna committee
and what we did is we eliminated the
entire section
from top to bottom and we started
looking at those agencies that we had
not heard from minor technical changes
but the areas that we heard loud and
clear from that from so many people
around the state those were not put in
we thought it more appropriate that Edna
take a thorough look we didn't feel that
the division could really do its due
diligence in such a short period of time
to address these changes and I'd like to
turn it over to representative McGuire
who can speak to some of the smaller
boards that we did in fact move from the
Secretary of State's office to oplc the
other thing that was concerning for us
on a financial matter if we took the
changes that had been suggested we'd
lose about
998 thousand dollars in general fund
money that comes from oplc so there was
a financial piece but more importantly
we turned to e-dna and again and thanks
representative McGuire for your
leadership and getting us here
representative McGuire Dan McGuire okay
well I could turn it over to the other
represent let me just explain so first
of all
um the last bit of what representative
leishman said I think is incorrect in
the sense that
um the house passed a bill that makes
um oplc an independent independent of
the general fund right so they'll be
they'll be self-funded from their
licensing fees so that was always that
was in the house bill too but it's also
in a bill that we just passed and so I
think that from now on anyways that
licensing will not be they will be
charging license fees
um equal to their costs so that it will
not be a money maker licensing will not
be a money maker for the general fund
um in essentially we took out of this
section
uh it I personally think that the
governor's
um
initiative here is well is is was a good
one and long overdue we we license we
have occupational licensing way in
excess of most other states
um including our neighboring states like
Vermont
um who have very thoughtful and and
limited occupational licensing by
comparison to US it's not an area where
New Hampshire
is particularly good in my opinion so so
I like the governor's proposal it just
turned out to be way too much for our
division to process and and deal with
the level of detail involved it's really
something that has to be done by the
Edna committee and given all the help
they gave us we really cut this down to
the to the Bare Bones
um the main person who's going to be
happy with what we have left is the
Secretary of State because the secretary
of state will no longer be doing
licensing for for the a couple of very
tiny board you know professions that
that he was dealing with
um
but we've kept
um a few a few removals there's there's
in particular there's four very tiny
areas that have never caused problems
that are that are being de-licensed here
um that's the uh athlete agents the
um Hawkers and Peddlers itinerant
vendors and one
no boxing is being moved to oplc
um I think there was one other one
oh no Allied Health is not a removal of
a license maybe it was just those three
yeah so um
Allied then there's a couple of sort of
consolidations in particular Allied
Health so Allied Health used to be the
the like at oplc of its own there were
there were a half a dozen small boards
and and Allied Health was kind of an
extra layer
Allied Health previously had been moved
into a oplc so it was a redundant layer
so so one of the things is this that
layer is going away there's a few other
small cleanup type things but but all
the the the the changes that were
getting you hundreds and hundreds of
emails those are all gone from this
amendment
so it's a very minimal Amendment it it
does a lot of cleanup but it but not in
a at all controversial way
question representative Edwards uh thank
you to the uh the McGuire Duo uh in
division one I I think this was great
work I agree with you that the
governor's initiative was was bold and
moves Us in the right direction and I
see where you're taking us in this this
bite at the Apple what what do you think
comes next what you know where are we in
the uh okay so what's next we'll let
Carol McGuire answer that thank you uh
the old
the Edna committee has two retained
bills
and two Senate bills and several Senate
bills coming to us that we're hearing
this this coming this week and next
so we intend to work first of all on the
parts that we specifically wanted to
take out of house bill to
the entire committee was agreed they
should not be in House Bill too and
that's the restructuring of the mental
health boards
the psychologists Board of mental health
and the
latex we have those those three boards
have been an issue and so we are going
to be working on what we should do about
them looking at the licensing
requirements and the way they operate
so that's one part we're also looking
specifically at the LNA license which
the governor wanted to delete but
we're not entirely sure that his
equivalency with the national
certification is right because there are
significant differences in scope of
practice so those two pieces we're going
to be looking at
while we look at the Senate bills other
items we will continue to look at there
is an oplc oversight board that is now
being formed that we expect to give us
other suggestions like making more
governing advisory and governing boards
rather than full-fledged regulatory
boards but
that's that's a separate issue we expect
we'll get to that next year
uh thank you representative thank you Mr
chair
Dean no further questions please proceed
all right I guess we can uh jump down to
page 56.
but actually before I go I Melissa did
mention to me there was a a house bill
that passed on consent last week which I
must have missed we're thinking it was
656 which
eliminated the lapsing of oplc so what I
stated earlier apparently that wouldn't
have been the case a week ago but with
the passage of this bill now all money
will stay within oplc but you could
probably help us out representative that
section was included in house bill 655.
it's also included in house bill for 45
I believe or 455 which is in Ways and
Means at the moment they're considering
how to handle the non-lapsing fund
oplc has always been self-funded from
license fees
what many of us are concerned with is
that by maintaining fees at a level that
lapses uh three or four million to the
general fund it's becoming a tax rather
than a fee and so we want to keep it
more focused on the ACT at just covering
the cost of the actual oplc operations
so I think we'll probably look forward
to a reduction in licensing fees the
first thing we're going that is in
process is a realignment because some
boards are generating a great deal more
than they cost and some boards are
generating much less than they cost so
there will be some realignment expected
fairly soon
thank you
hey moving on to uh
page 56 Mr chairman this was just giving
the consumer Advocate which is within
the department of energy
the ability to move funds around for
consulting or litigation but the
transfers are limited to seventy five
thousand dollars
so now we go to page 57 through 58 many
of you probably recall this was a house
bill 347 was introduced by
representative Lind I believe to have a
land use judge again this has gone
through the process past the house
and it's just adding an additional
you'll see in the judicial budget later
they've added the one additional
Superior Court Judge to their budget but
this specifically was to try to handle
the land use cases at this Superior
Court
thank you
so going on to page 59 Department of
Corrections for position relocation
allocation again we don't see an awful
lot of money here but that's why you're
seeing the language the governor May
draw a warrant for for General funds but
again we've had a real problem with
Staffing it as you all know at our state
prison so this is looking further into
pay classifications and other
Assessments in the Department of
Corrections
page 60 again all about expansion
recruiting retention program
various the Department of Corrections
has put together quite a document
dealing with Recruitment and Retention
again this kind of just ties into the
same thing
again we're still with corrections this
is on page 61.
this was brought forward by the
commissioner
as far as a burial expense trying to
help families uh that have lost someone
that's worked for the Corrections
Department there was a loss recently at
the Corrections Department and the
commissioner felt we should at least
provide some sort of funding for that
expense now it's not to exceed ten
thousand dollars
page 62 we heard from the Department of
oh sure representative McGuire
I just like to comment on the direct
Department of Corrections
um because this isn't a department that
is in Dire Straits
um their employees they they have
roughly 50 percent of the number of
correctional officers that they really
need to run the prisons and so the
correctional officers that we do have
are working a lot of overtime
um so when I spoke to says he's working
64 hours a week so so 24 hours a week
well maybe slightly more of required
overtime he has no choice about working
overtime and in addition to that parole
officers who normally don't work in the
prison at all are working up to maybe 16
hours or so of overtime and in addition
to that National Guard members are
working in the prison so so they are
signifi efficiently shorthanded so so in
a sense we rather than fund building a
new prison we put in as much as they
asked for for operations and and
improving their situation and operations
and part of that is going to be getting
some of their officers reclassified into
higher grade levels so they they can be
paid more and hopefully help them with
recruiting in that way but this is an
area that that really needs help and
anything we can do just as general
advice anything we can do similar to the
juvenile case to Res to lower the number
of uh people going into prison would be
helpful as well so something to think
about anyway
that's for sure
representative Edwards has a question uh
thank you Mr chair you mentioned the
National Guard have been deployed into
the corrections system
not everyone appreciates that the
National Guard come from the community
come from employees of the private
sector or other state agencies and so
when they get mobilized they end up
being unavailable to work their regular
job and so
um
so I think it's it's a particularly bad
sign when we deploy the State National
Guard into a mission like this because
it's distracting and they're supposed to
be available for for other crises that
are not man-made this is a man-made
crisis we should try to solve I think
it's and then you could make that a
question I suppose do you agree yes
representative McGuire yes thank you the
corrections situation is one that
essentially convinced me to vote for
house bill 436.
Corrections Officers are considered
policemen for the purposes of the
pension system and the state employees
who are affected by House Bill 436 are
overwhelmingly the Corrections Officers
not the state police
so
they are
some of the people that most need the
pension improvements and we have heard
that they are going to stick around a
little longer because of House Bill 436
and the pension improvements so I hope
that will help
so you know further questions please
continue
thank you Mr chairman moving on to page
62.
we heard from the Department of
Agriculture again this is a bill House
Bill 230
that they were way behind the times and
as far as their uh
electronic licensing and certification
registration so this is a one-time ask
of 360 thousand dollars
for them they're presently occupy acting
and as he said probably the 18th century
when it comes to running their
Department
moving on to another very important
topic that was discussed at length
within the division as uh I was built
I probably should turn this over to
representative evil who was no she's
shaking her head no
hmm
so again this is something that
representative evil and others have
worked on for a long period of time uh
trying to get a handle on food waste
disposal it does create a new position
within the Department of Environmental
Services for about 98 000 in the second
year of the biennium this was a position
that was supported overwhelmingly by the
waste industry Waste Management I
believe they came to testify in others
so we thought this was an important ad
going next to uh
page 65 and 66.
I learned something with this one I they
said they were this is again the
National Guard for recruiting and
incentive program and they said that
money would come from Their fines and I
thought they were collecting Their fines
for traffic violations and come to find
out there are court martials that aren't
removal of the offices but fines for
infractions so that's where the fine
language comes from but they're looking
to expand their incentive programs for
staying or signing up to be with the
National Guard
moving on to page 67 this is food waste
reduction and diversion this is another
item that was uh
looked at very seriously by the division
it was a fairly large ask of two million
dollars but the division felt we should
get a handle again on waste and where
it's where and how and especially food
waste disposal which we found was uh
shocking the amount of tonnage that
we're loading up on our landfills with
food waste so that's where this came
from it came out of the environment and
agriculture committee unanimously
uh
next we have
page
68 this is requiring The Liquor
Commission to at least provide some
notice again this is something that I
know representative americh
knowledgeable on in the former chair of
the finance committee sitting I think
behind me keeping an eye on us but we've
just asked on the fiscal committee that
we get some notice in advance of closing
of liquor stores and the executive
Council has actually been added to this
which we did not have in the original
amendment that was offered two years ago
by representative Ober that was taken
out by the Senate
some years ago we had an item before
fiscal committee and it was the closing
of seven liquor stores and I was reading
it at home at the same time I had the
annual report of the State Liquor
Commission and I looked and it had
several years of their sales and whether
they were declining or increasing
and what do you know the seven liquor
stores that were on the list to be
closed had all been been declining in
sales while almost all the rest and I
think there's about 42 almost all the
rest were increasing in sales so it was
obvious it was an obvious business
decision once you looked at the annual
report what was the effect why were they
closing these has nothing to do with
politics we want to keep politics out of
this this is an entrepreneurial fund we
want them to make as much money as
possible so it's it's used for good
purposes all the money that comes out of
the the
liquor liquor sales so
I thought yes they had made good
business decisions I saw the evidence of
it so I would never question why they
closed the store and I don't think we
should
I guess this is okay to have a to have
some warning especially for the people
that are regular patrons but also for
the employees and generally they always
find a new place for the employees they
keep the same numbers liquor stores
consistently and as they find a better
location they move to it and they get a
pretty good rate on the rents as well so
this this is okay I don't want to see us
get too involved in meddling with where
the stores are placed thank you
thank you Mr chairman um
moving on to
page 69 through 70. uh
those of you that are familiar with pfas
probably everyone has heard of it this
is changing a few things right now it's
a loan if someone has been affected
we're looking to change it to a response
fund two years ago it we put about 25
million into this fund there's about 12
million dollars left
so
it on that one
next one is uh
71 page 71 and I'm going to poke a
little fun at my colleague to the left
you probably recall that there was some
excitement on the house floor last week
again this house bill 50 which this is
sets aside 50 million dollars towards
the unfunded liability again it did pass
last week on the house floor and some
people were concerned that
representative McGuire's moved to table
this was a stunt to kill the bill well
it was a strategy that's not often used
but we thought it would work well the
house would vote to support this and as
representative McGuire and all of us on
division want to discuss this we thought
it was a way to strengthen our position
and then this is just showing yes it is
in the budget so for those people that
were concerned with the tabling motion
that was the strategy and representative
McGuire I thought was a pretty good
strategy because of the importance of
this particular item to us on the
division treat you like to comment
further no that's right okay
Edwards for a question all right uh
thank you I I haven't I haven't been
following this particular item very
closely is this the one that uh goes
into a direct payment on our unfunded
liability and the effect of that is it
will reduce the amount of cost that
needs to be shared with the uh the
subordinate elements of government and
the individuals you're absolutely
correct yes so this particular
payment will this is actually 2023 funds
so so as soon as the budget passes
hopefully with this in it
um 50 million dollars will will be
transferred to the retirement system to
pay down the unfunded liability the net
effect will be that that the
municipalities and the state will pay
105 million dollars less over the next
couple of decades as we pay down this
unfunded liability
and just just for comparison what is 50
million as a as a rough percentage of
the total unfunded liability it's
extremely small right yes it's under one
percent close to one percent but under
one percent all right thank you
any no further questions please continue
moving a page 72 this is a rim system
that you've probably heard about there
is an appropriation in the capital
appropriation of 24 million dollars it
was some concern by the commissioner
that there may not be enough funding for
this so this gives the department the
ability to seek further funds should
they be necessary
okay
so this next one 73 this was a an
amendment that was offered by
representative Weiler
there as all of you know there's been
some concern about getting House Bill 2
to us and
in a relatively quick fashion so
representative Weiler has added this
language that not later than February
15th of the year that the biennium
session that we should have house bill
to
so 74
again this was uh it was an awful lot of
discussion on this particular items it's
a house bill 571 again retirement this
was a cost of living adjustment for
group two retirees the division made it
a one-time
contribution towards if you will
recognizing that people have seen great
costs increase and group two employees
haven't had any adjustment for some time
representative McGuire worked on this
and came out with what maybe some will
say is a difficult scale as far as
figuring this out it wasn't everyone
gets three thousand dollars at two
thousand dollars but representative
McGuire worked on a sliding scale which
he may like to speak of but the division
felt it was fair based on time served
with a maximum benefit of three thousand
dollars I don't know if you'd like to
add anything else
if there's questions
I don't see any questions
so 7 76 again an amendment that was off
offered by uh representative Weiler this
is often uh just clear language as far
as it's put in the budget every year uh
providing reports to the fiscal
Committee of where we stand again normal
language I believe
quite often requests come to the fiscal
committee for another stipend add to a
budget normally we say where do you
think we're going to get the money from
so this way we'll at least know if
there's fairly good lapses coming around
from all the other departments then we
know where the money will be coming from
and we won't be overspending when we
approve an item in fiscal thank you
the next Amendment which is identified
as 77 in your packet this was offered
through uh representative Weiler in the
public works committee
something we weren't really familiar
with but short-term rentals for the
different departments have to go through
the Govern Council which holds up
projects especially in emergencies so we
thought that a waiver could be supported
that short-term rentals would not need
to be before the governor and Council
representative boiler
representative Karen McGuire yes thank
you I'm looking back at on page 76
if this report to fiscal is something
you it is included in the budget every
year why don't we add it to statute
instead of leaving it in chapter law
well in effect it will it will be in
statute when we put it in hb2
well I I beg to differ that it it won't
show up if you're looking up the
many people including many
representatives are not aware of chapter
law
and find it difficult to find
items that are only in chapter law and
therefore if this is something that you
want every year
which sounds perfectly good to me I
think it should be under the duties of
the Department of administrative
Services I'd like I'd like to recommend
that be the case thank you I will follow
up by filing a statute next year but the
problem was
um
you know when we see fiscal where's the
money going to come from so anyway
thank you
so if the chair would like us to go to
some of the uh
detailed changes that are significant or
yes
let's do that
so you'll notice a lot of items have
been changed some have not been changed
so I'll try to hit some of the more
significant changes that
we did by at least adding Personnel or
we did address a number of extra wants
that were requested by a number of
departments
you'll see there's a lot of
duplication if you will for doit there's
one line that goes to dot but it's also
the funding that comes from the agency
to support doit so people get somewhat
concerned they think it's double
accounting which is just the way
unfortunately we do things because doit
is all other funds that come from either
General funds or federal funds but
these are by category of
of the funds what category is doit
and you'll see like doit is all other
funds but they can in fact be federal or
general funds uh there were some
ads as far as trying to strengthen the
Liquor Commission they had requested
additional
add-ons for software development or
licenses upgrading and maintenance of
the existing computer systems if you go
down to the board of land and tax
appeals there were some issues about
case
management data upgrades that's on line
17.
we talked about this earlier about the
support staff needed over at liquor for
again positions to support their
next-gen software there are two
positions there on line 19 and again if
I'm going too fast just please put up
your hand or
press your button so I'll see the red
light
again this was mentioned earlier some
additional tech support for the
Department of Revenue Administration
on 20 line row 20.
so let's see some other uh the
commissioner of
the department of administrative
Services had a number of requests that
were not included in house bill one
and uh
you'll see those on 25 and I think
the significant ones there is the space
the renovations going on at the annex of
about 1.2 million dollars it was
requested
the commissioner again of Das made a
strong case that we're not keeping up
with our facilities in the state needs
more money for maintenance roofs that
sort of thing upgrades and that is 3.6
million dollars for the biennium online
26.
uh
you'll see a number of
departments there were no change we did
make some change with the office of
child advocate they needed additional
funds for travel they have to attend
conferences
out of state their travel line was
pretty insignificant so we added
something there
additional training funds and also to
fund a case management system we were
told that they were falling behind on
keeping track of these cases which has
become problematic so you'll see that
additional want there of two hundred
thousand dollars
then going on to the next significant
changes are line 48 Governors page 52
again technical specialists
that will be with the rim system
you'll see going down there vehicle
Fleet is in disrepair so they've asked
for additional funds for some additional
vehicle replacements
something again it was mentioned earlier
with the audit division or two new
positions for out-of-state audits again
we saw that there'd probably be a
significant generator there of Revenue
of in the neighborhood of 1.5 to perhaps
two million dollars
for the biennium
again as we you know cruise down through
here again they this is a good example
going to a board of tax and land appeals
line uh 65 on page four where I talked
about that earlier with the oit there
was a line for the 1905 here you see it
uh near line so it's a
they're making the appropriation which
that amount of money will go over to
doit
um
the other the judicial branch they these
were some significant reductions there's
quite a few of those that the judicial
branch came forward with
and we saw no reason to challenge any of
their
reductions
a soil going down again continuing down
Department of Agriculture markets and
food that's line 15.
on a row 15 additional position for a
soil conservation position the
commissioner made a very strong point
that this was a necessary position and
we agreed
now the Department of Justice had a
number of requests that were granted by
the governor especially for elderly
um
abuse it's a becoming a real problem
within the state as our population ages
we're seeing more and more elderly abuse
so the division supported an additional
person to work within the elderly of
Fraud Unit so this will be an attorney
to work within the Department of Justice
and this is one of their additional
requests that we thought was needed and
should be funded
uh the others going down again row 20 is
just a simple transfer from the
Department of Justice or to the
Department of Justice
from the Department of Environmental
Services the Civil Bureau
this is we've we felt and it was
supported of course by the attorney
general that the legal folks should be
embedded within the secret of the
justice department and not perhaps
embedded in the agency but should work
directly out of the justice department
so this is one of those changes
um
then we go to Transportation
attorney position for the transportation
and construction Bureau so again they'll
be working with the Department of
Transportation as far as their legal
representation
a long spot of no changes Again The
Liquor Commission I probably see those
is uh those were mentioned earlier on
the doit section further in the front of
the doc package
so going to page seven uh you see
there's no changes in the uh
site evaluation public utilities and is
representative McGuire mentioned we as a
division fully supported Corrections due
to their ongoing issue with retention
and operating in a state prison system
so no change and that's a significant
part of our budget all of that is
primarily General funds it's a
huge chunk of money we don't get a lot
of support other than our general tax
dollars for the state prison system
going uh
over to the I believe it's almost the
last page page eight
uh
there was the Bureau of historic sites
uh again we spoke about I think that
earlier
the moving the fund from hb2 to hb1
General funds versus uh
Park funds
in an item that has gained a little
attention and is going down to line nine
the New Hampshire public television
there was a request within Governor's
budget for five hundred thousand dollars
each year there was a lot of debate
within the division but at the end of
the day I believe we were unanimous or
very close to it
with not recommending the 500 000 as it
was a new ask there has not been an
appropriation for New Hampshire public
television since representative
valencourt was here and moved to have
that stricken to evolve funding and that
was about a decade ago
uh other issues that just draw your
attention to because they're a
significant but there are other funds
but this will have an impact on going
down to line 17 or row 17 Again
uh the Winnipesaukee River Basin These
funds are collected by the users they're
about 10 communities that this is a
wastewater treatment plant that's around
Lake Winnipesaukee towns and like when a
Squam about 30 000 users there's some
deficiencies within the plant uh
upgrades that are necessary so the
department asked that we would support
this request again these are funds that
will be raised from the users not the
state but does require the state to give
their blessing
so the others uh
going down is uh
some I guess
the one of the more significant things
uh there's hazardous waste cleanup fund
uh
this is an alignment of including some
positions that will be necessary there
with the case was made to add some
positions
to deal with hazardous waste cleanup and
also solid waste the solid waste
programming probably not aware maybe you
are that the state has several two I
believe
dumps that are now the responsibility
responsibility of the state to maintain
so
the owners can't be found or located so
the state has an obligation to continue
to monitor those landfills and there is
a cost to that
so representative McGuire and I are free
to answer
any questions or if we're at a loss
which is occasionally does happen we can
turn to our LBA staff to bail us out
any any remember having a question
please push your red button so I can see
it and identify
obviously uh
okay
representative wildner followed by
representative Stringham Mike's just
I'm just going to ask you to go back up
to
um
line 12 on page eight I just wondered
what the um transfer of that position
from legal aid to the Department of
Justice was I missed I must have missed
the description
thank you
page eight
what's that
representative Wallner has gotten a
little below the weeds apparently for us
so
Mr Hoffman is going to try to answer
that question
the Department of Environmental Services
has various
administratively attached boards and
they rely on the Department of Justice
for hearings and those sorts of
procedural things and this would move a
position that was in Environmental
Services over to justice for that
purpose
representative Stringham for a question
yeah if it's okay I'd like to go back to
an earlier line is that okay
yes sure um we have already included
this is follow up on the HB 436
Amendment and we had already included
inductions in this budget and in a
biennium where we're seeing real
reductions in revenues and increases in
cost driven by inflation I would have
thought you might have advanced stopping
future decreases or at least holding
future decreases in ID not accelerating
the next biennium reductions I think you
offered to say why you thought that was
important and uh I I would like to give
you an opportunity to talk about that
thank you very much representative
um I do think it's very important in my
mind the interest in dividends tax is
the most economically destructive tax
that we have and then here's why
essentially when when people have money
there's two things they can do with it
they can spend or they can save and as
we know when we tax something we get
less of it
and the interest in dividends tax is
specifically a tax on savings lots of
our other taxes our taxes on spending
and some taxes are sort of intermediate
in the sense that
um we don't know what whether their
attacks on on spending or savings
because there's some combination there
for example
um
let's take the communication tax for
example that's a tax on spending right
it's a tax on spending on use of phones
use of use of communication the tax on
business profits and business Enterprise
that could be a tax on either we don't
know if if a business had more money
would they consume would they would they
spend more or would they save would they
put money towards capital projects but
the interest in dividends tax in
particular is a tax on savings its
attacks on investment
and savings and investment in economic
terms is what makes tomorrow better than
today it's it's in order to if if you
simply consumed everything you produce
so in general you cannot
consume more than you produce that right
that that produces debt which is sort of
negative
economic activity but
um
if you uh tax savings and have less
savings that makes tomorrow not as good
as it would have been otherwise right so
so when you save money and invest money
that makes tomorrow better than today
and and in economic terms that's
happiness right that's that's
um as long as things are better right as
if tomorrow's better than today if the
day after that is better than that and
the day after that is better than that
we have a rising standard of living we
have Rising incomes and so on
If instead we tax savings like the
interest in dividends tax
we cut down on how good tomorrow is and
that's making life worse that's making
um that's reducing our standard of
living compared to what it would have
been otherwise so in general
um we want to increase savings we want
to increase the economic activity in the
future that makes things better to the
extent that we this is another reason
why I want to pay down debt faster with
things like house bill 50 because to the
extent we have debt debt is the opposite
of savings and it's making things worse
in the future so so in general economic
terms
we want the future better than today and
and
the the interest in dividends taxes
specifically poor in that regard
any other questions from the committee
please push your mic button so I can see
the red light
representative tolerski for a question
followed by representative Heath thank
you Mr chairman I have a question about
a relatively small amount of money on
page three of the detailed sheet from
the office of child advocate
um
we've all
seen over the last year or two some
tragic cases of
um
involving children in our state
and I believe a lot of that
um was referred to the the case
management system needing to be upgraded
I'm curious if this small amount of two
hundred thousand seven hundred dollars
was added on to go above and beyond what
was allocated in the governor's budget
or if the governor's budget just didn't
have any funds
for this ask
this was a new ask the governor did not
support it so the two hundred thousand
dollars is a new they had asked
specifically for that amount thank you
very much sure
I
yeah so I'd like to add just in general
there's a lot of extra in this budget
both from the governor and from us
for
um for it for for
adding systems right and and improving
um improving the use of computerization
and uh for example liquor has a big
system that's new dra Das and so on and
just in general we have trouble hiring
so anything we can do with computer
systems to improve productivity means in
the future we won't have to hire as much
which we're having trouble doing but
we'll be able to rely more than we have
been in the past on technology so this
is an example of that
representative Heath for a question
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
representative at what point does the
foreign individual does the IND tax kick
in
if you're asking
specifically there's a
um there's a separate
um
there's a limit of different for a
single and for couple I don't know
specifically
um
maybe what I have in the back of my mind
is twenty four hundred dollars
yeah 2400 for an individual 4 800 for a
couple worth of that particular kind of
income yes
and I think it's it's doubled for over
65.
that sound right Mike
I think there's an extra exemption for
over 65 I'm not sure if it's doubled or
not though thank you
so there is one other thing that
representative McGuire and I thought
might be helpful in the entire division
for the rest of you to hear we did a
deep dive in the governor's request for
a
44.9 million dollar in um
23 in the uh
54 million dollar 24 appropriation it's
section
within the house bill too
and everybody said well this is a
significant amount of money but we asked
the department of administrative
services to come back to us and give us
the real dollar amount as far as the
benefit cost those people getting pay
raises on other funds federal funds and
it has a significant increase which I
think you should all be aware of because
it was one of the largest items in our
review but it doesn't come to the
surface because there was no change and
so in 24 for all funds for this proposed
increase it's 101 million dollars
and then in 25
the all funds for the increase is 123
million dollars and I I point that out
because it's a significant amount of
money but the division was entirely
supportive of that and felt that all our
employees should get the 10 and 2
percent respectively increase
moving forward so again I just wanted to
make you aware of those numbers because
it's a little different than what you
may be seeing when you go through House
Bill 2 in the specific section
also an indication of how many of our
employees are paid not through General
funds but through Highway funds or fish
and game funds or other funds or federal
funds so that was kind of overlooked
when we first saw the budget because the
first pay raise was only shown in
general funds thank you that's correct
pointing that out
I presume Emirate for a question thank
you Mr chairman
when I was on division one I remember
working with the commissioner of
the prison
what's it called come on correction
Corrections Corrections thank you very
much
and one of the problems then I'm
assuming now was was the turnover in the
guards
because they go they get trained about
80 percent of the police academy uh and
so they did have a little tiny bit to do
but then they get hired by the towns to
go be a police officer
so I suggested to the commissioner that
she uses that as a hiring strategy
join our team for three years and you'll
be a graduate police officer
so it reality is they're losing their
guards outside make it a strategy This
is Our intention
and if you happen to stay great but what
we're hiring you for is go work for
somebody else
a little tongue-in-cheek but you never
know
you're absolutely right representative
American unfortunately has not changed
but the commissioner Helen Hanks is
doing a very good job she's put together
quite a package with her team about
retention to try to get us headed in the
right direction so they're well aware of
and they're they're working hard to turn
it around and that's probably a good
suggestion to put out there as well she
does an excellent job thank you
I don't see any other red lights
I would hope we could do
um
a motion from representative leishman
and representative McGuire to accept the
proposals we have heard these last hours
from division one both hb1 and hb2 any
objection to doing them both at once
seeing none I'll move that chairman
Weiler
representative McGuire's second
clerk will call the roll on the
the finance committee acceptance of the
report on hb1 and hb2 from division one
excellent report thank you
thank you Mr chairman a good morning
representative Earth
yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Carol McGuire yes
representative colfat yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Cambridge yes
representative mower yes
Representative walner no
Representative norgren no
representative leishman
yes
representative buco
no
representative Hatt I'm sorry
representative grassy no
representative Hewitt no
representative Heath no representative
Murray
no representative evil yes
Representative no
president haykin Phillips
no
Stringham no
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman of vote is 15 to 10 in the
affirmative
15 to 10 in the affirmative the motion
is adopted and we're open for further
amendments
at least Russia press your red button if
you have an amendment representative
Hewitt
sorry
representative McGuire
and thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
move Amendment 1228.
um and I'll speak to my motion if I have
a second
all right we'll return to that when it's
distributed
I'll need a second
I'll second that
thank you
foreign
Mr chairman so
um we had a house bill House Bill 276
from representative rung that had to do
with
um
funding um creating a new fund to deal
with cyanobacteria
which is a problem for for lakes and
um
and other bodies of water I guess and uh
so we're originally the original Bill
House Bill 276 had a very problematic uh
funding mechanism it intended to borrow
25 million dollars and then give it out
as as grants and and possibly loans and
and it just it wasn't workable as as it
was and we didn't really have time to
deal with it so previously we asked this
committee to retain the bill which you
did
now uh subsequently last week
representative rung came to me and said
could we pass this bill without the
money in it and I said sure why not and
uh but it turns out that a retained
motion is something that cannot be
reconsidered it's one of those few
things that once you do it it's it's
done and so
um this this amendment would put House
Bill 276 into House Bill 2 without the
funding mechanism this is what
representative rung would like and I
think we should support it and then she
has ideas for how this could be changed
uh together with the senate in the
future so
um that's that's this amendment
further discussion
seeing none
I'm a motion by representative McGuire
followed or seconded by represent Petrie
to adopt Amendment
1220h does everyone have a copy
representative McGuire is recognized for
further come
the unleash me whichever you only want
I don't know if anybody has any
questions if if it's at all confusing
representative erf has a question
so this talks about setting up a Loan
Fund could you just describe how that's
funded
right so this particular Bill simply
creates the fund puts a dollar in it so
so there's no money here but they have
ideas for how they can make changes to
this structure to attract federal funds
so but that's something that's going to
be worked out with the Senate
thank you
representative Miller for a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions
um the language says that those are low
interest loans
what is the you know standard of and
where does the money to make those loans
low interest come from
yeah that would be up to Des and how
they decide on those particular details
thank you
is there any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on the acceptance of
amendment number one two two zero h
uh thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire
yes
representative Peter votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Carol McGuire
representative colfat yes Paul
sorry
representative Sweeney yes
representative yes representative
Mueller yes
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
representative Leachman
yes
Reginald Buco yes
representative grassy yes yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes representative yeah
yeah I was in haken Phillips yes
there's any Stringham yes it was in a
water that Mr chairman a vote is 25 to
nothing in favor of the motion
it is adopted and added to hb2 are there
any further amendments to be
recommended
seeing none that was an excellent
representation by the team of four from
division one thank you very much thank
you Mr chairman
representative emmerich are you ready to
begin division two for a little while
uh Mr chair
representative Edwards what is uh your
intention about lunch uh do you expect
to go all the way through uh division
two or take a break halfway through what
what what's your concept
I expect it take a a break around noon
we'll let we'll let them get started and
and we'll
let represent emmerich know that uh
we'll we'll likely stop at some good
point when he gets to noon thank you sir
thank you
all right
the
finance committee will now be attentive
to the
description of the changes made by
division two of the finance committee
recognizing
excuse me representative Emrick
representative Petrie and Mickey
landrigan
thank you Mr chairman first I'd like to
thank the work of the committee and
Mickey particularly who kept us honest
and on track
uh so thank you very much
uh I'd like to start not jumping into
the packet necessarily I I there's every
now and again there's something that's
quite large and it's like what just
happened if you turn to the bill packet
uh page 21
you will find uh
Amendment 1105 and I'm going to do it
first because it appears all through our
my documentation and if you don't know
what it is it looks very strange
what this is is the chairman of Finance
decided we've got to go back to the good
old days in the good old days the
education trust fund was established
because of a court case
and it was set up to be funded from
various sources
over time
that satisfied the court and so we move
forward with the educational trust fund
in 2011 I believe when there was a
budget crunch
uh the educational trust fund which is
what was a fund that could only be used
for education
and and did not lapse
so it it was had money in it so what the
the committee did at that time is they
took items that had been paid for by
General funds and moved them into the
educational trust fund and so as time
passed more items migrated into the
educational trust fund because it was
getting more and more money
uh and the reason it was so well funded
is back in the day when it was
established there were probably 220 000
students in the state
and all of these funding sources came in
and everything was kind of balanced out
uh and it was designed to be just enough
or not quite enough so that General
funds often were used to make up the
balance
well over time as the student population
drops because when I joined Finance I
mean uh yeah financing about nine years
ago I think there were about 220 000
students today there were numbers are
bandied about about a hundred and sixty
thousand or 155 000. however the
contributions to the fund have never
changed
so the fund gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and we Shuffle more and more
things into the fund uh to try to spend
the money down
well the chair said enough is enough and
put put forth this amendment 1105.
what 1105 does is it goes back to
setting the moving a lot of the funding
out of the educational trust fund into
the general fund
what it does specifically
is it modifies contributions from the
BPT the business profits tax and the
business Enterprise tax fixes it at
twenty two and a half percent each
uh which what this does in the next
biennium is that it will contribute not
contribute it will allocate
approximately 222 million dollars in uh
fiscal uh 24 and in 25
it will allocate about 225 million
so what what this does is it moves the
money out of the educational trust fund
into the general fund
and I if you have any questions we'll
ask the chairman I would like to add
further
I was here in 1999 when we created the
education trust fund and the adequacy
formula we spend a lot of time just
deciding what would go into the adequacy
formula
and it was only adequacy it wasn't
special ed it wasn't building Aid it
wasn't tuition and transportation all
those items came out of general fund and
so I spent about 20 years on division
two and it remained as basically
adequacy
after some big tax raises tax increases
rather tax decreases both by
um
Federal by Trump on bringing business
taxes back from overseas and also the
fact that our tax cuts were bringing
more more business taxes in so as as the
chairman noted
the shrinkage of the population we were
covering for and the increase in
business taxes the governor's budget
proposed cutting it from business taxes
from 50 percent going to the education
trust fund to 35 percent when I looked
at all the excesses that were coming in
education trust fund I believe we should
go back to its historic for over 20
years use just for the adequacy so I had
LBA reduce it to 22 percent which
brought it closer to just covering
adequacy it I think it did Cover a few
more things but if we have to put money
in a trust fund and we end up end up
with a surplus that's money we could
have used somewhere else but are unable
to just as if you wanted if you had a
surplus in the highway fund you couldn't
use it anywhere else same with the fish
and game fund so it remains in that fun
but if we're short somewhere else in
general funds it's because we took money
out that we did not need to cover
adequacy so by going back to its roots
and it's it's mostly 20-year history
that's why I put in that Amendment so
that the education trust fund would
cover what it was always intended and
what a historically funded so that's why
I put in that Amendment and I thank the
Division II for accepting it
thank you for bringing that up
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to start
with the hb1 items
and I've just got some prepared remarks
here
many of the changes are relative to the
budget entry Corrections required by the
Departments the corrections are detailed
on Rows 2 3 4 5 11 10 and 11. the other
changes recommend by the department of
safety and hb1 were not funded in the
governor's budget but we're all part of
the Department's prioritized needs
request
row six in in the area of e-911 increase
for Consultants to assist with enhancing
Network protection from cyber attacks
funded with e911 dedicated Revenue
row seven three new firefighter
instructors for the fire academy funded
by the fire standards and training and
Emergency Medical Services fund known as
the fire fund
row eight
two new program specialist positions to
perform Health Care Facility inspections
these positions were abolished in the
governor's budget from DHHS and were
mistakenly omitted from the Fire
Marshal's Office budget this was the
department of safety's top request these
are general fund positions and you're
going to see this again because the
positions were coming over from HHS
row nine one program assistant position
in the Fire Marshal's Office to help
with planning organizing coordinating
division of fire safety including
administrative rules and processing and
responding to requests for in
information complying with RSA 91a
requests for 91a have increased over the
last few years in 2020 the department
received 132 91a request in 2021 they
received 159 91a requests and they are
on track to receive 197 in 2022 nearly
a 50 percent increase since 2020. this
position would be funded by the fire
fund
row 12 in DMV provide additional funding
to cover credit card processing fees to
avoid posting the costs onto customers
an item to do this
for FY 23 was approved by the fiscal
committee March 24th this would be an
impact on the highway fund as it would
come from DMV's cost to collect
administer Highway fund Revenue
under Fish and Game
the only change recommended is to
establish a senior accountant accounting
technician this is fish of the game Fish
and Game funded position the department
has a similar position prior to the
shared services initiative from a few
years ago
duties were owed back to the agency but
the position was not which is why they
requested it for this budget
the fish engaged came budget by division
two includes approximately 2.5 million
of general fund support
prior periods support was 1.25 million
part of the reason for that is during
covet everybody went fishing
and they're not fishing so much right
now
under division two recommendations the
fish and game fund balance out of June
30th 2025 is expected to be
approximately 4.5 million same as the
governor's recommended budget
Department of Transportation
General funds added for the state to
provide match to Transit agencies to
access additional
iija federal funds I believe the
committee received a letter from
councilor Kenny relative to this
with many co-sponsors included
what this is is transportation that is
federally that is federally directed but
locally funded and so then the
transportation providers are every time
they go on a transportation for one of
these runs they lose money and that's
this is an attempt to help them with
that
funded both Highway
funded both highway-funded additional
prioritized needs of the department
requested petition division two Row 3
funds provided for the replacement of
equipment Vehicles this was the
Department's full request this and the
next item with the only two dot Highway
fund additional prioritized needs Row 4
funds provided for vehicles telematic
devices
row five six and seven technical budget
changes row five and seven entry errors
asked to be corrected by the department
row six additional apportionments and
needed to align with the white Ways and
Means Highway fund Revenue estimates
this is the 12 percent of Highway
Revenue that is distributed to
municipalities in the following year
Department of Education
roasts 2 13 14 and 8 18 Net Zero changes
just moved programs from education trust
fund to general fund as part of the hb2
amendment 1105 that we previously
discussed Row three increased the
tuition or Transportation Aid to
districts relative to Career and
Technical education programs level
supported by the chairman of Education
Rows 4 through 12 all relate to the
Department's request to update certain
positions labor grades and starting
Steps From what was entered into the
budget system back in the summer
when they expect will be needed based on
what they expect will be needed now this
is a total cost of approximately one
million dollars General funds
and about a hundred and ninety thousand
dollar federal funds
rows 15 and 21 costs associated with the
direct hb2 Amendment for the Department
pursue Medicaid direct certification
this includes one new full-time position
contract costs and additional nutrition
reimbursement Aid to districts for fy25
Medicaid direct certification would not
impact adequacy until 2020 FY 2026.
we currently use uh the uh
Medicaid direct certification for TANF
and for snap
so this is nothing new
rows 16 and 17 funds added to cover
costs associate associated with episodes
of treatment
uh this this relative to HB House Bill
521 which is recommended to be retained
similar to the court order placements in
the footnote the statutory change in hb2
amendment allows for the doe to pay full
costs from the general fund should they
exceed the amounts budgeted what this is
is uh
like it's like a court-ordered placement
but it's done by in for medical reasons
uh row 19.
change in adequacy funding associated
with hb2
Amendment 1170 in total for the biennium
it is 39.3 million over the governor's
budget and approximately 158 million
more over the biennium than current Law
formula
row 20 increased reflex hb20 Amendment
1139 H which increases the additional
Charter School Grant to four thousand
three hundred dollars which paired with
the increase to the base adequacy in
Amendment
1170 brings the total per pupil base for
Charters to nine thousand dollars
division two retained representative
Mooney spill HB 272 which had similar
intent
Lottery Commission division two
supported both Lottery Commission
requests row 24 added authority to
expend to doit for the development of
centralized CRM solution Software System
Division One support of the doit budget
change for this request
row 25 budget entry correction funds
were in the wrong class line in
Governor's budget
police standards and training Council
adds funds to continue the Statewide law
enforcement accreditations program
it was started in foi 23 with arpa funds
and pstc asked for it to continue with
General funds no federal funds are
available
this was pstc's only request
community college system
of New Hampshire no change from
Governor's recommended budget hb1 there
are many hb2 community college system of
New Hampshire amendments in the
amendment packet which we will cover
University system of New Hampshire
additional 2 million
from fy25 block appropriation which will
enable UNH to keep in-state tuition
Frozen through FY 2026.
and those are my comments for the hb1
questions from committee members please
press your red button so I can tell you
are getting my attention representative
Murray followed by representative
Carol McGuire that is representative
tlerski you trying to get my attention
you didn't push the button I did I set
it off after you recognized represent
mark thank you representative Murray
thank you Mr chair and thank you for the
presentation for the people at home who
don't have these sheets would you please
on page four read line 18 and explain
what's going on with line 18.
page four I'm sorry page five line
eighteen on the long sheet sorry about
that my apologies I thought it was a
Never Never Land
well this is part this is part of the
reshuffling of uh this is building Aid
which West was part of the
education trust fund and has now moved
out into for General funds yes could you
read the numbers for the people at home
since they don't have the sheets
oh okay
uh
educational trust fund in FY 2024 is a
negative 86 million nine hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in FY 20
2025 is a negative 87 million one
hundred sixty seven thousand dollars for
the biennium total of 174 118.
as I explained earlier these
traditionally for 20 years were in
general funds rather than education
trust funds so we're restoring to what
the historic uh records were
if you want to see the offsetting
entries for that if you go to page four
row two
thank you
what do I have next representative Carol
McGuire then represents solorski
thank you Mr chair I'm curious on Page
Six
line 30 33 2 million to the UNH to
freeze tuition
how many New Hampshire students are at
the University of New Hampshire
I have no idea
thank you
representative childerski for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question back to page five
line 18.
what jumps out at me here is that
special education Aid is being moved to
the general fund as well as a number of
other things
does this mean in general terms that
money that has
collected primarily for spending on
education
is going to be moved to the general fund
and potentially could be spent on
anything else
it's restoring it to where it was
historically there for 12 or 20 years I
have special ed money came from general
fund I appreciate that Mr chairman I
just want to clarify so that I'm fully
understanding the ramifications of this
that monies that have been earmarked for
certain educational costs such as
special education will no longer be held
in the education trust fund but will be
moved to the general fund to potentially
those funds could be spent on anything
else it could be
thank you for clarifying that
any further questions from the committee
representative uh Heath
um thank you Mr chair and I've asked you
this question before when we made the
major move
um just my question is with regard to
the education Freedom accounts and why
in fact they were not moved into the
general fund if you would please answer
my question thanks
I don't recall where they were moved
representative Emrick
they're still in the educational trust
fund
because they're part of adequacy
correct
right
further questions from the committee
members
representative Waller
similar question I'm wondering why court
ordered placements
for children have been moved into the
general fund
that's where they always were
and they were under this they were under
the special ed when it was generally
funded to
there is no reduction in money spent for
Education we are just putting things
back where they always had been this is
not any reduction in education this is
not any harm to education this is
putting things back we always funded
them
is there any further on hb1 from
division two
seeing none
this would be a good place to take a
lunch break till about one o'clock and
then we'll come back to go over hb2
changes from division two thank you
you're in recess till one
foreign
everyone with house House Bill 2 from
division two
uh representative Emery
thank you Mr chairman there was a
question before lunch about how many
students were at unh
I have two answers the university system
as a whole has approximately 23 000
students
about 50 percent are in state 50 out of
state UNH specifically has 15 000
students
thank you
okay I'm gonna go a little off script
again
you have a couple of documents one is a
horizontal document that has some yellow
highlighting
and the other has several columns this
is the adequacy program
that we were talking about being
funded by the education trust fund so
what I'd like to do is just uh use the
the governor's presentation
he'll be served he'll be referred to as
the left side of the equation and the
right side of the equation
if you look at this document that has
the yellow highlights you'll see three
columns the current law Governor's
recommended and then what was Amendment
1170 provided for
uh you will notice the
current I'm not going to talk about the
current law
what what you have here in the columns
with all cities and towns is what your
municipality or your school district can
expect under the new Under the new
formula
so if you want to get what the governor
called a spreadsheet War says something
like that get the spreadsheet War out of
the way get look it up you know know
what's going on
uh
uh basically what the governor's plan
did was it upped the base and the fnr uh
as and so
what we looked at was is the governor's
plan a good plan and by and large the
committee felt it was a pretty good plan
because they had on what's now the
second page
which is the right side of the equation
the governor did have accelerators for
uh communities in Greater need
the committee
decided after some encouragement
that we wanted to step on the
accelerator a little faster
than the governor as far as increasing
the adequacy for needy towns and that
those towns are have
equalized valuation and for f r
what this does is it puts more money in
the in the needier towns quicker than
the governor's plan and at a higher
level we added 20 million dollars per
year or 40 million dollars for the
biennium
what this does is if you go to the
second page
under you see extraordinary need grants
under the governor's plan the grants
were up to 650 dollars
under what was proposed from division
two
grants up to
3750 dollars
now this is not every student gets three
thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
they have to qualify to have a
equalized valuation under a million
dollars
and then it if you're over six million
dollars you get don't get any of this at
all and between those two it it ratchets
down the better off your community is
so
we didn't change we didn't change a lot
the uh we did change the two percent and
this was in the governor's plan we did
go to two percent annually instead of
two percent by on the biennium
um
if you want to see the the total the
total change in funding
on page two the governor's extraordinary
needs grants were 89 million and
I'm I'm sorry 9 million
and 9 million
I'm having trouble one of my contacts
fell out
well our our
budget goes down because we have higher
extraordinary need grants so the
money we spend is 40 million dollars and
the governor proposed but we allocate it
much more heavily to towns that really
need it
so that's
that's the adequacy we did do some also
make some changes to sped and uh English
language Learners just rounding the
numbers that's
going from 2079 to 2100 things like that
other than that
if somebody has some questions on this
I'll let Mick answer them
push your red button if you have a
question
representative McGuire followed by
representative Heath thank you Mr
chairman so the extraordinary need Grant
of the 3700
50 is that on top of the 2500 on the
first page
yes okay and may I follow up so
do you know roughly how many are in the
group on the first page compared to the
group on the extraordinary needs Grant
I don't understand the question so is
there
a hundred thousand students in one
group and ten thousand in the other or
as well how many students are involved
some Ford form of extraordinary needs
Grant yes
don't know don't know and don't know how
many on the first page either
spreadsheet
it shouldn't have extraordinary need
okay
representative Heath for a question
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr chair for taking my question
um I think Mickey's probably going to
end up
um answering this one though
um we looking down this list
um we see um places like Berlin uh the
city of Rochester
um there are a number of places that
really are not seeing
um what we'd hoped that they would see
with the proposed um change in the
proposal for the funding
um I believe that that with the
um subtraction of stabilization which I
understand has been something that we've
been trying to do
but um what what do you think we could
do in terms of getting some more relief
for some of these towns I I just am I
have to say I'm really worried about the
fact that many of our towns are kind of
getting a double whammy based on the
fact that from 2019 through 2023 we used
the same kind of data because of covid
and now we're using real-time data as
well as a change in the formula so
school districts are not only seeing
reductions in their fnr because they
didn't fill out the white paper forms
that they're supposed to fill out
um and and
um again some the enrollment numbers are
lower than they were a lot of kids are
coming back to Public Schools but a lot
have chosen other options so school
districts still have to run their
schools they still have a classrooms the
same number of classrooms they still
have to provide transportation what what
could we do what else could we have done
in terms of maybe weaving something else
into the formula to to give our those
towns like Berlin a little bit extra and
like Rochester
um Mickey I think you're probably going
to be the one to answer that let me let
me give you for the first part is the
fact that the governor's plan and our
our plan has hold harmless so nobody's
going to get less
than they have the previous by any so
now
you're on
so
the elimination of the stabilization
grant for many communities is not fully
made up by the additional Aid infused
into the extraordinary needs Grant
that's essentially why you see many
towns held at zero or using that hold
harmless to remain at what the fiscal 24
projection was so the examples that you
said Berlin Rochester those would be
towns that their stabilization grant
that they lost
was greater than the amount of
additional extraordinary needs even with
the additional 20 million per year added
in division two
follow-up
so um
could we have Incorporated
um stabilization
um at let's say if we did a quarter a
quarter of what it was previously what
would that have done
I can't I without being able to run that
I can't tell you specifics of course it
would have resulted in less hold
harmless being required sometimes would
have still had a stabilization component
to their their adequacy Grant but I
can't speak to how many more towns would
have received additional Aid if for
instance stabilization would remained at
25 versus all the way to zero
don't forget for many years we've been
paying for students who don't exist
based upon earlier projections as as the
population of students goes down you can
expect the money to go down so you can't
keep paying for students that don't
exist we have done that for several
years in several iterations I don't
think we can continue thank you
representative papavichi Mueller thank
you Mr chairman I just wanted to state
that we did spend a lot of time in
division to trying to find ways to
achieve those goals and frankly to
summarize all our well to summarize what
I learned in that process I don't want
to speak for anybody than myself but
what I learned is that our current
system is so fundamentally broken by the
many many patches and Band-Aids that we
applied over the years that the only way
to
help those you know
outliers that are not getting the help
in here is to put so much money into the
system for everybody else that it's
beyond the ability that we have to pay
for it right now so
we do have to fix this formula and I
think this is the best achievable way to
get there while it may not you know help
every community that we'd like to help
but we are doing the best we can overall
and we try to increase the fairness and
address that so it's just a very tough
challenge thank you
represents string and followed by
representative Murray I was wondering if
you could comment at all on why the
extraordinary needs Grant is based on
just free and reduced lunch and not
general population I go to a place like
Berlin there's a four bedroom house for
sale for 57 000. go to a place like
Newcastle there's nothing available for
less than seven figures so uh you know
certainly a factor is that the number of
students uh per per uh dollar value of
property
and why is the grant just only targeted
free and reduced meal when when towns
may not have any students with free and
reduced meal are under calculated them
may have just as much need my
understanding and all that my LBA
Pro do it answer the question my
understanding is that the equalized
valuation and fnr are both woven into
the formula
and so like Newcastle you know they're
they're their valuation could be five
million dollars I I'm making it up but I
mean
so the the extraordinary needs Grant is
a current law
component to the adequacy formula and
that was not changed in the governor's
proposal nor division two with the
exception of that Max Grant so as far as
a component that would be equalized
valuation per all pupils something
existed used to be called fiscal
capacity disparity Aid that was that did
that that was repealed a couple years
ago
and extraordinary needs Grant was put in
its place that that merged free and
reduce and equalized valuation into one
component
thank you
president Murray for a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you and I think
you I genuinely thank you for all the
work we worked hard on a lot of this the
entire committee worked very hard on
this but um I feel I have to you know
make a point here I heard you say that
the goal of this was to try to get
additional funds to communities that
really needed it the poorer communities
that that was one of the things that we
considered in putting this together
if I'm looking at this I don't find any
additional fun going to any of the
communities that really really need it
and so can I phrase it like this in
rather dangerous terms would you agree
with me that we did not succeed in
reaching the poorer communities
I have to say I I would hope that we did
but much like representative Heath
it doesn't look like we didn't look like
we achieved what we thought we were
going to do
thank you for that I appreciate it
we did achieve something
but
representative hack and Phillip thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I just wanted to draw our attention to
the last page of the highlighted
comparison sheet
specifically in the hold harmless Grant
section
where I think it's important to
acknowledge that the grant amount is
reduced by 20 over each of the next five
biennia
and in pointing this out I'd just like
to see if you also will agree with me
that it is it is true that the folks who
do
receive the benefit of the hold harmless
uh Grant in this biennium that we're
discussing now will will see a reduction
in that hold harmless Grant in the next
many bienneas to come so the statement
that no one is harmed by by this new
calculation is in fact not accurate
because they will see a reduction
in the necromium in in the following
biennia right well I'm talking about
this one
somebody else on the hot seat next
biennium can do it
any further questions from committee
members seeing none please continue okay
now we'll get back on script
and we'll go to the proposed amendments
fairly Hefty packet
uh
the first item is the appropriation
community college system of New
Hampshire
dual concurrent enrollment program this
is the running Start program
where high school students can start
gaining college credits while they're
still in high school it was represented
as a very successful program
and and quite Dynamic around the state
so we did we did amend it but it's still
doing very well
uh appropriation University system of
New Hampshire for the Whittemore Center
originally it was came in at eight
million dollars uh subsequently the the
chancellor came back and said well 6
million would be fine there and 2
million will move over to our adult
program in the universe in the
University system
so uh we approved that one
New Hampshire excellence in higher
education endowment fund the unique fund
uh has no money so it was deleted
for the Department of Education for uh
computer science professional
development this is a a train the
trainers program if you will where
they're going to try to improve the
computer skills of the uh
uh teachers so that they'll get a
teacher get well trained and go teach
other teachers
we approve that Department of Education
Commission of New Hampshire Civics uh
the next two deal with that we didn't
really think that the Department of
Education really wanted to be in the
publishing business this was actually to
publish a book
and so
so we left the commission we re
restructured the commission so that it
has it includes one parent that has a uh
pupil in public schools other than that
we didn't fund this uh activity Beyond
setting up a commission which I know the
speaker is going to be very happy about
um
the next item is the weight permit fees
application of receipts all this did was
add over height
as another one of the items that can be
that they can have a fee for because up
to that point this was for over length
over with but not over height so now we
can have a fee for over height
and Human Services I mentioned about
this one uh the the
Residential Care Facilities will move to
the Department of Safety
uh
uh state budget allocation for gross
application from Highway fund
uh
I can't even read my own notes
it's just so it was suspension of an
allocation yeah right yeah we deleted it
that's right
um
education Freedom accounts eligibility
uh moved in one
location to 350 percent and another
location is still specified 300 so what
this what this amendment does is
normalize 350 in both locations
uh
uh this educating trust fund
distribution this is part of the uh 1105
Amendment where the educational trust
fund moved into General funds
building Aid and building grants there
was the governor's budget had a 75
million dollars
in an item of building Aid that became
effective June 30th
2025. representative tolerski has a
question thank you very much Mr chairman
um I just wanted to go back to page 12.
on the education Freedom account program
eligible students
um I understand that the
change to 350 is there any other changes
to the program that happened in this
amendment in terms of who can
participate
well there's two there's two bills that
pertain to this 464 and 367.
one actually added
um
additional criteria
and the other one was was the one that
changed it to the 350.
but the one that added additional
criteria did not have any specified
income
okay so when I I didn't read through
this completely yet having seen this for
the first time but the the references to
foster care migratory child was there
any other
um changes to who actually qualifies
regardless of the of the income
eligibility I'm just
no
say it again yeah no okay you've seen it
all yeah
okay
keep the party going
uh Department of Education appropriation
CTE renovation projects
I think that's another one of the 1105
adjustments
spell out the page you're on oh I'm
sorry
page 62 bill paid six or the dude okay
I got so many notes Here
right here 14. okay
uh
I just went over page 21 I just went
over that's the side by side that we did
looking at adequacy
the charter school funding is uh
House Bill 272
which
that's a good one
uh
which we actually retained and
incorporated into the budget we talked
about that as being nine thousand dollar
total now
page 14
the business profit tax again this is
1105 where it goes to 22 and a half
percent for bet and BPT
uh
page 27 division of analytics and
resources a new petition for academic
research and Improvement for for data is
a is an ad
page 28 Department of Education
application for medic Medicaid direct
certification
uh as I said when we're talking about HP
one
we're currently doing this for the snap
program and for TANF so this is a pilot
program to see if we can do this for uh
free and reduced lunch
analysis or numbers
as was said the the free and reduced
lunch forms are not coming back at a
great rate because it's been two years
to get untrained about submitting these
forms so the fnr is probably going to be
down because of the reduced applications
page 29.
is a subscription to the national
student Clearinghouse student tracker
program which it was represented it will
give more information of what happens
with our High School seniors and college
matriculation and and we understand
Beyond uh
so this is a subscription representative
Heath has a question I just um I had
asked this in committee too and we
didn't get an answer can um I don't know
if there's somebody here that knows what
data set is used to gain that
information what's the tracking
methodology for the to get the
information for the Clearinghouse if
anybody knows
I think it was Greg Hill that said this
was successful he'd heard about it
somewhere else I don't know he didn't
spell out exactly how they got it but
it's he felt it was fairly active I
loved I like the program I'm just
talking about the data set how they're
doing the match
I'll I'll check with the Department a
bit thank you
representative Mueller do you know the
answer my understanding from discussions
I was having with the Department of
Education but I would still follow up
anyway is that the data is reported by
the various colleges and basically this
is a national program that has a
Clearinghouse where everybody reports in
and they you know match it as well as
possible and report back to the states
in question but I cannot say that I'm I
can go into the nuts and bolts of the
details the Department of Education what
no more
further questions from committee members
seeing none please proceed okay
page 30 is an appropriation community
college system of New Hampshire for
Workforce credential programs this is
two million dollars primarily focused on
reducing the cost of re-education for
adults that are considering professional
or Life Changes
uh
the promise the next one on page 31 the
promise program is targeted at
underprivileged in order to attend the
community college system
page 32
math learning communities program public
secondary schools what this is is a I
won't call it remedial math it is making
sure that high school students are
proficient enough in math to go to
college
that's what this program is designed to
do
and and we passed this already in house
bill 419.
a general fund transferred to the
highway fund when we looked at the
highway fund it was starting to kind of
scrape the bottom of the barrel
and so we decided to appropriate 20
million dollars to the high oh no 7
million 10. I got it
10.
to the highway fund just because they
were getting very close and then snow
season wasn't quite over yet so
and in the past I think last last uh
term the Senate actually put 20 million
dollars in the highway fund just to keep
it
solvent
uh
uh and we are
Department of Safety contact system this
is for a system and if if there's people
have special needs and there's an
emergency people within the safety
department knows who those individuals
are to provide a additional Aid this was
also passed in house bill 560.
the last item is the Department of
Safety uh the division State Police
Appropriations for a bail uh
stat condition status what this is is if
somebody gets
put arrested in Hampton and they have to
go into unbail they get bailed out they
get in their car and they drive to
Laconia they get in trouble in the
cornea
the Laconia bails person doesn't know
that that person's already on bail
so what this does is it basically is a
database of who's on bail
so that
if somebody's already on bail they just
violated their bail by doing whatever it
is they did to go have to get bail again
so that this was a last minute addition
to the to the mix and it was
appropriated for one million dollars
this was a request from the chairman of
the criminal justice committee he said
he had several other bail bills that
were kind of dependent upon this
information being available so if we
didn't pass this it made several of his
other bail bills not very Worthy
thank you
and that concludes
my formal presentation
and I would move the acceptance of hb-1
hp2 Division II
represent Petrie do you second I do
okay representative Petrie did you bring
the uh list with you I sure did you're
on top of it thank you very much
so the motion now is to accept the
report of division two for hb1 and hb2
and after we vote on that we can be
entertaining further amendments so is
there any questions before we go to that
vote
rip
thank you Mr chairman I will be voting
to support the work of this division
although there are things in here that I
don't like I'm not a fan of
education Freedom accounts
but there are things in here there are
good additions to our budget process
and in all good faith I couldn't vote
against this division after the work
that was done in my division and the
important things that we did so I will
be voting yes to support representative
emrick's motion
further discussion from committee
members
seeing Nani ready for the question the
clerk will call a role the motion is to
accept the report of division two for
their changes to hb1 and hb2
clerk will call the roll thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes president
Petrie votes yes representative Tracy
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Carol McGuire yes
representative colfault yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrose yes
representative Mueller yes
Representative walner no
Representative norgren no
no representative leishman yes
representative Buco no
representative grassy no
representative Hewitt no
representative Heath no
representative Murray no
representative evil no
Arizona tolorski no
version of haken Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative Weiler yes
Mr chair the
vote is 14 to 11 in the affirmative
thank you are there any amendments being
offered for many members
chairman Weiler we do have five division
two related amendments so I can take
those up I the first one that I have
here is for representative McGuire I'll
pass that out here
so I'd like to move Amendment uh 1078 h
okay representative Maguire moves
representative 1078 h
it's a one-liner is there a second
Wyler seconds
thank you
I should have prepped that better I
think yeah all right
is recognized to explain the amendment
thank you very much so
um this removes the Whittemore Center
um six million dollar
appropriation from which is I believe
section well it was originally section
10 of house bill 2. I don't know what
section it is now but the 10 and 11.
um
everybody has sort of their favorite and
least favorite parts of the budget and
this is for me my least favorite part I
think
um
it's it's just inappropriate public
spending in my mind we get our money
from from people all over the state many
of them from Modest modest means we
charge a large amount of property tax
and so on so so everyone comes
contributes
and in this case we are taking their
money and using it to buy a hockey rink
um a hockey arena and to me that's just
completely inappropriate it's not like
much of the other things we spend in the
budget where people are children or
disabled or sick or elderly and so on
um or even core functions of government
like like justice and prisons and all
that these are fans and participants in
hockey and it seems to me that this
would this item
must be the easiest thing for the
University to raise money on their own
right I mean this is be very attractive
to fans of hockey people they could sell
seats they can sell bricks they can
raise money and so on so I just think
this is a this is an inappropriate
expenditure
now you might ask well okay if we save 6
million since this is the worst part of
the budget maybe we should add 6 million
to some other part of the budget right
and in my opinion any other part would
be an improvement
but in this case I have not proposed to
add this money back into some other
section but instead just to leave it out
and
just in general I think you know we
don't have to spend every single last
dollar and if we leave a little wiggle
room for the Senate that means that the
things that our our priorities when they
add their priorities they would have to
change our priorities less if you see
what I mean so so this is just simply a
cut not not a balance in some sense
thank you Mr chairman representative
Heath for a question thank you Mr chair
um
the University of New Hampshire serves
our state well
we have a Workforce that comes directly
from them the Whittemore Center is not
only a hockey rink
um the purpose behind this is to
actually
offer essentially seed money that will
be doubled and tripled by many private
donors but those donors are looking for
an understanding that the state of New
Hampshire believes in the University of
New Hampshire funds the University of
New Hampshire
this is a small amount of money that we
can step forward and there will be other
donors who will step forward because we
have stepped forward we have not funded
this I I'd say in this biennium we are
doing the best we probably have done in
a long time but this is important for
the University and I think it's
something that it's time that we use
this as a step forward now the
Whittemore Center is used for many
purposes
um it's used by many high school teams
when they play have their playoffs it's
used as a entertainment venue and it's
also a venue that can be used to drive
more funds for the University of New
Hampshire so I would ask you all to vote
no on this amendment and move forward so
we can support the University of New
Hampshire Whittemore Center thank you
representative Hewitt for a question
oh I'm sorry I didn't I didn't realize
I'm a machine
thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
representative for taking my question
um from my memory of the testimony we
heard from UNH when we were discussing
their budget trimming from the 8 million
to the 6 million presented
um and which we're now contemplating
deleting that line item
um the test money was stated that not
only were the you know UNH division one
hockey players
um taking advantage of the ice and the
facilities but also para Olympian and
other disability based teams who train
in that Center as well so I think is it
correct that the earlier comment that
this does not
um help our children across the state
who have disabilities incorrect In fact
correct
representative Edwards for a question
followed by representative Murray uh
thank you Mr chair not many people know
that I grew up in the in Nebraska and
they have a strong football program
there and they spend a lot of money on
it because it's a big part of the
culture
the state appropriates no money to the
athletic department of the state it's
responsible for supplying all of its own
Revenue to cover all of its own costs
and knowing that over the last two
decades there's been a facilities arms
race where schools are competing each
other with each other on the basis of
nice facilities I can appreciate the
whittemore's request to upgrade their
facility I would just say that I don't
believe that's a state responsibility
because that's the way I grew up thank
you
present Murray for a question thank you
Mr chair
um just um seconding that this is an
important public private Enterprise
which I think has great benefit across
the state and to that and uh when I've
been there it's not filled with students
it's filled with families who aren't
really associated with the university
and it's a fairly expensive in night or
night out for everyone to be able to go
there so it's used well well beyond your
sense of oh this is a university
Enterprise a bunch of University
students there I was really taken aback
of the number of families who are there
for a pleasant night out
and it is a revenue stream that can be
an additional Revenue stream the
Republican convention was held there one
year it was filled there are lots of
opportunities we talked about the new
um
concept which is really new to me of
e-gaming and having all these sort of
competitions it's not just that they're
building this place but that it enhances
a revenue stream that brings in more
money to the University of New Hampshire
and also I think I recall in um the
testimony that the students at the
University of New Hampshire 50 coming
from other places and 50 staying here
like New Hampshire intend to stay here
so the University is also providing a
venue for Workforce where these students
come here and they decide they're going
to figure out how to stay in New
Hampshire and having
I hesitate a little bit to use the word
amenity because it goes way beyond that
but having a university that is
competing at a national International
level is bringing in fabulous students
that we want that we want to stay here
so I think that this is an investment
not necessarily in the University of New
Hampshire although it is it's an
investment in the state
president
thank you Mr chairman and it's a comment
really
um having been the other State Rep that
visited I do agree with representative
Murray that the upgrades to the
infrastructure are needed they don't
actually affect the rink itself the rink
is fine the way it is but the weight
rooms and there are a lot of things
underneath where
the athletes that compete have less than
ideal facilities which indeed affects
recruiting so I absolutely see the need
for UNH to upgrade those facilities but
having been one of the few people who
voted against this in my division
it's not that I don't see the need it's
that I don't think that the need is
compelling enough for the state to spend
money that are kind of desperately
needed elsewhere and our unfunded
liabilities come to mind that
you know we we have to do this but I
want to make it very clear that I fully
agree that in order for the sports
program to stay competitive they do need
to improve
it's just you know
not something that I'm comfortable
sending General funds you know funds too
thank you
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman this is this is more of a
comment I want to thank the vice chair
of my division representative McGuire
for bringing this amendment forward uh I
will be voting no on the amendment
though and I think in this committee
when we're voting no on a financial
proposal whether from a division or as
an amendment we should explain why we're
voting now so that's what I'm going to
attempt to do here
this budget is going to have a lot of
pills in it that we all have to swallow
I I mentioned in division when one when
we were working on our elements of the
budget I think if each of us put
together a budget that we would want
individually there'd be 400 budgets in
the state of New Hampshire that we'd be
considering I respect and I thank the
work of division two that looked at this
part of the budget they worked among
themselves in good faith on what they
presented to us today and I support the
work that they put forward in
um and I look at this we can we can
debate the philosophy on whether State
funds should be used on this should not
be used on this but I think it's a piece
of the budget package
that is going to make it easier for
others to swallow different pills in the
budget they may not want to swallow it's
not going to be a budget that I think we
can all
uh swallow each individual pill but as a
Morpheus it's something that we can all
get behind and if this is something that
is going to help others support the
overall final package I'll vote to keep
this in the budget by voting against
this amendment but I do hope we're all
operating in good faith in that we can
get to a budget proposal either by the
end of tomorrow or by the end of
Wednesday that we can unite behind as a
committee because I do think that's
important for the people of New
Hampshire from what I've heard from the
other divisions and I know we had a
great time on division one putting
together our proposal and and we heard a
presentation from division two and I'm
eager to hear division three a lot of
work was put into it I don't want to
second guess the work the divisions have
put in and I do want to make sure that
we can build a budget together that
works for all the different pockets of
New Hampshire so I appreciate the
conversation the you know and I probably
in a
separate matter would say you know
no to the Whittemore Center I think it's
an impece important piece to get this
overall budget passed and that's why
I'll be voting no uh hoping that we're
all engaging in good faith to to get a
budget finalized that we can all support
and swallow the bills with thank you
Mr chairman
I just want to make a a point this is
actually coming out of surplus funds I
mean there's still there's still State
funds but it is Surplus and it is a a
coordinated effort at the University
because the funds that are coming in are
from donors sponsors UNH itself and the
state and Par I I got a call from an
alumni from 73 encouraging me to support
say we really need to know the state is
behind the University
so
I'll be voting no on the amendment
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you Mr chair and this is a
question to the amendment sponsor
um so I understand it there are a lot of
tensions at the end of uh our stay at
the Whittemore Center as a legislature
and that there were rumors that we had
been kicked out and asked not to return
and so would you consider an amendment
that would designate the Whittemore
Center if we put money into it as the
secondary off-site location for the
legislature should we ever need it again
and I'm not entirely serious but I I do
think there's a point in there
thank you for the question
representative fortunately I was not a
member of this uh body at the time so
I'm I'm going to defer judgments on the
CFO has confirmed that for free if if
this passes
Mr champ
representative Griffin
I I have a question if I may
did this come in at a larger figure
originally and it's been cut back
already yes it came in at 8 million
I probably will be supporting a no vote
on this amendment
any further questions from any of the
members
seeing none the clerical collar role on
the motion to adopt Amendment
1078h to hb2
thank you Mr chairman representative URF
yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie vote I'm sorry
uh representative Petrie votes no
representative Emrick no
representative Griffin no
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards deference to the
chair no
representative Bean I'm sorry geez
representative uh
Aguirre sorry
blame me for that one
that's a yes
representative uh
yes
representative Sweeney no
representative cambrose yes
representative papovichi Mueller
yes
Representative walner no
Arizona no
[Music]
president Leachman no
representative Buco no
no representative uh grassy no
Arizona Hewitt no
version of Heath no
representative Murray no
representative evil no
Representative no
there's no hake and Phillips no
there's gonna Stringham no
representative Wilder
yes
Mr chairman the vote is seven years 17-0
any negative
ocean fails next Amendment
so so we have two Amendments of
Representative Heath and we'll pass them
both out together
are we missing someone
are we missing someone because this was
announced as a 7-17 no
whoops should have been
Mr clerk are we missing anyone yes we
are I was checking on that and we did uh
it's eight
it's eight to Seventeen which is 25.
it is 8 to 17 different number okay
yeah see thank you Mr chair I'd like to
um introduce I have two amendments and
I'd like to introduce the first one is
um an appropriation it's uh amendment
number 1202h it's appropriation to the
Department of Education adult education
the sum of five hundred thousand dollars
um in the fiscal year ending June 30th
uh 2023
um is hereby appropriated to the
Department of Education for the purpose
of increasing funding available for
Grants to adult education programs
during the biennium ending June 30th
2025. this appropriation shall not lapse
the governor's
um so the purpose of this amendment is a
simple one
um it's come to my attention that um
due to a regional formula change a
number of dis school districts adult
education programs have had their
funding reduced uh for example example
Dover Nashua and some other districts as
well and this appropriation of five
hundred thousand dollars to the adult
education line would help to at least
mitigate to some degree that change in
funding so I'd appreciate a yes vote on
this amendment thank you Mr chair
how much is already in that line
um I think it's about 4.3 million each
year
a 4.5 million Mickey
at the eight
I'd have to look that up
it's in approximately 4.5
and our adult education programs across
our state have done yeoman's work
um so many of our our youth who become
different disenfranchised with school
have gone on adults coming to this
country from other
um Nations have been able to get their
high school diploma or high school
students have been able to make up a
course through adult education so it
serves many purposes
foreign
Edwards for a question
um I I assume this is General funds are
not coming out of the education Trust
good question Mr thank you um the um
funds will be coming out of General
General funds yes
further questions from the committee
representative Petrie yeah I need a
second on that
representative Murray seconds
Murray
was it Maria grassy Murray
oh okay
Murray I got Murray down representative
did you have a question I just had a
comment
on the amendment
um
the director of the Nashua Adult
Learning Center reached out to me when
they discovered this
oversight and how the funding formula
had
drastically impacted what they were
planning on receiving
the amount of services that they provide
has really skyrocketed in the last few
years and this will be a small
correction to try to help them stay on
track they do a phenomenal job in
educating new Americans that will help
our Workforce in terms of all kinds of
life skills English language Learners
they also have some child care services
so parents can continue with their
education and I hope everyone could
support representative Heath's Amendment
thank you
representative papovichi Mueller thank
you Mr chair I just I'm trying to
remember if this was ever discussed in
division two and I'm not sure if this
topic came up I mean I know we talked
about the appropriation as a whole but I
don't remember this formula issue if you
could maybe help me catch up
if I may miss cheer
um
thank you for the question
um I did not know about this
um issue in the beginning when I asked
the commissioner of Education
um he explained that um he thought that
there were sufficient funds in that line
um because I had wanted to increase that
line and he said we really didn't need
to and then I became because of the
change in the formula and the concerns
that have been raised by various
entities
um it came to my attention and I did go
and speak with the chair of division two
and at that time that was the day that
we made our major move in terms of our
funding thank you to chair Wyler
um so I did not get a chance to really
bring it up and do anything so I asked
the chair if he would be comfortable
with me doing this today and he said it
would be okay
just a quick follow-up
um did you have the opportunity to reach
out to the you know commissioner or the
Department of Education tour was it just
you know us and the people you already
mentioned
uh yes um as a matter of fact on on
Friday during fiscal the Department of
Education was here and I asked the
representative to go back to the
department she couldn't answer the
question so she went back to the
Department of Education and she inquired
and she came back and explained to me
that there had been a change in the
formula that's why those communities
received a lower allocation
thank you
representative Edwards uh yes sir thank
you for the second comment I I just I
would want to point out that in the
division III budget there's a section
for refugees in which we do pay for
Education such as English as a second
language and if we were to spend this
money it might be better to spend it
over through DHHS where there might be
some matching money available
um and uh I'm I'm gonna vote no on this
because I'd rather see this money go in
to increase the amount that we're going
to put into the Medicaid uh
reimbursement rate increase
representative McGuire yes thank you Mr
chair
I'm very curious about the this formula
do you mean the formula that determines
how much each School District gets or
what
you know the department told me it's a
regional shift in the formula
um that
um gives out the I believe the federal
dollars
so follow-up
so is this who owns this formula and why
was it changed
I was only told that it was changed by
the federal government
thank you representative Dan McGuire did
you have a question
thank you Mr chairman you might expect
representative McGuire ask my questions
two great minds
further comment of questions from the
committee members
sing none the clerk will call a role on
the motion to accept Amendment one two
zero two h
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
now
representative McGuire no representative
Petrie votes no
representative Emrick no
representative Griffin no
representative Mooney no
representative Edwards no
representative
um
yeah
who's in fit being
Maguire
a great mind gives a lot gives it up let
me see I know
okay uh representative kofalt now
president Sweeney
representative Campbell's
River representative popovichi Mueller
no
Rosanna Waller yes
representative norgren
representative leishman yes
yes
thank you
oh
motion fails
uh Mr chair I uh respectfully will
decline to come forward with another
amendment thank you
any any further emotions
all right
thanks
thank you
so Mr chairman I would move amendment
number 1175 H so that I could explain it
representative Murray moves
representative Griffin seconds that we
adopt Amendment 1175h
representative Murray's recognized
Mooney
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee I appreciate uh you
indulging me here amendment number 1175
H is an exact replica of a bill I
sponsored this term House Bill 354 which
is currently retained in the House
Education committee I apologize that it
looks onerous but this is simply what
this amendment does
public charter schools are not allowed
or permitted to Simply apply
for school building Aid
this does nothing more than allow public
charter schools of which there are
approximately 28 in the state
to Simply go through the process like
any other public school to apply and
then have the district vote on The
Ultimate Building Aid through a warrant
article it's an onerous process
you may recall when the Department of
Education came to testify in front of us
about some school building Aid items I
asked the question are public charter
schools the only Public Schools excluded
from the ability to apply for school
building Aid and the answer was yes
so this bill keeps the school building
aid process intact it just simply allows
those public charter schools that own
their own buildings
so now you're up to about two or three
in this state only those that own their
own buildings would be allowed to apply
and go through the process like any
other Public School in our state
there is no fiscal impact here
my house bill 354 has no fiscal note
another thing this amendment does
is it corrects currently a glaring
contradiction in our law
so glaring in fact that when we had the
department of Ed in front of us to talk
about appropriating money for a position
so that someone could go through all the
education statutes and re-codify them
they used this example as the reason for
the position
this amendment would take out the
section in current law that says no
Charter Schools May apply for school
building Aid
but it keeps the section in law that
says they may get up to 30 percent of
the project if they go through the
process appropriately and are awarded
School building Aid
we cannot let a glaring defect like that
in our law continue in fact to the point
that the department of Ed has had many
questions and it caused confusion
so with that description I would
respectfully ask that this committee add
this amendment to House Bill 2 in order
to put public charter schools one step
forward to be on the same footing as
traditional schools and correct the
glare in the current statute thank you
Mr chair
representative leishmanford
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question could you
tell us why the education committee
tabled it and didn't move it along
thank you representative
I could give an answer
um not speaking on behalf of the House
Education committee
however two things come to mind
first of all they've retained a host of
rather sophisticated School building Aid
bills
some of which to change the formula
change the process change the timeline
change the deadline and so naturally it
would make sense to retain this as well
and include it as part of that bundle
also in my introduction of House Bill
354 to the house education committee
there was talk about well who owns the
building if it were to dissolve what
happens in that case
my bill my Amendment addresses that and
also the Department of Education has
Provisions about who owns the building
in each Charter if a school were to
close
but that's my opinion as to why it was
retained of those two issues I've
discussed this with Amy Clark my
original bill at the department of Ed
she oversees School building Aid so she
and I have had discussions about this
um that is my my thought with regards to
your question
but I would if I could just remind uh
members that of 28 schools charter
schools in the state approximately only
two or three own their building and this
amendment applies only to charter
schools that own their own buildings
thank you
representative Wallner for a question
tell me
how
how a school a charter school that owned
its own building what would happen if
they did
um
they dissolved the school dissolved how
would you how would you handle
building Aid that had been given to that
school
thank you for that question
representative I would direct you to the
first page of the amendment line 613-19
uh with regards to
its dissolution being subject to a plan
for the disposition of the Charter
School's assets
and then it quotes an RSA as approved by
the State Board of Education
so that clause
was designed to specifically address
exactly your question
two years ago I put forward a similar
bill
and this was this Clause was not
included and so as a result of
conversations I've had and to address
the very question you ask I've inserted
that section
any further questions or comments from
the committee members representative
Edward
thank you Mr chair
you and I haven't talked about this in a
long time so you're going to give me an
education I think if if you can remember
the conversation I I had pointed out
that I understood the Pinkerton Academy
to be in a third category not a public
school not a chartered school but some
other category and I had asked if this
could be written in a way in which the
Pinkerton Academy could also become
eligible for school building Aid because
they are not now and they serve the kids
of uh three of my towns Chester Auburn
and Candia and so I I'd like to know if
my residents might be able to benefit
from a bill such as this
okay thank you for the question I do
recall the conversation I further recall
that when we had somebody from the
Department of Education in front of us
you asked that very question and a
follow-up was promised I don't know if
it was given to you
I am unsure
that that is a separate any the
Pinkerton Academy is a separate category
from a traditional public school or a
charter school my understanding was
Pinkerton Academy as a traditional
public school that just draws from
multiple communities as my
impression my recollection is Cole Brown
and Pinkerton our public academies it's
the way they're listed in as you say in
the third category the neither charter
school or public school they're um they
get the tuition money that each student
brings with them
and they don't they don't uh
request any building Aid and I think
built a great deal
any further questions or comments from
committee members representative Heath
thank you Mr chair just in relation to
um Cole Brown and and Pinkerton Academy
they are um
public private they have a Board of
Trustees they collect tuition from
whatever just sending districts go to
their school
Pinkerton Academy was eligible for CTE
grants
a Career and Technical education their
Vocational Center and so they were in
fact eligible for that they are not
eligible for many of the federal
programs but they are a unique category
and they are not considered a charter
school
think I said that
seeing none the clerk will call a role
to adopt Amendment
1175h on hb2 from division two
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf
representative McGuire
Roshana Petrie volcise representative
Emrick
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
representative Edwards
representative Carol McGuire
yes
representative colfault yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative Mueller yes I was in a
walner
yes
Arizona norgren yes representative
leishman yes
yes
representative grassy yes
you would yes president of Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes
and Phillips yes
yes representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler
Mr chair the vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
amendment is adopted
is this working okay
yeah it seems to be
foreign
Mr chairman I'll be glad to address this
representative Emrick is recognized to
introduce Amendment 1185 to hb2 thank
you Mr chairman in our last session we
approved house bill 572.
in that bill we basically made available
a meal during school day
with qualifications 300 percent three
times uh poverty level
however the bill had no ceiling it was
an unlimited warrant to charge the
Department of Education
what this what this amendment does is it
puts a ceiling on how much the
Department of Education can pay out
basically saying they can't pay out any
more than they have budgeted
so this was basically to correct what we
might refer to as an oops
uh very technical term
uh
and that's what it does it doesn't
change
anything to do with 572 except putting a
lid on the spending
this bill should have come to us
in the regular course of events the
chairman of Education said he was so
swamped in bills he didn't get to all of
them in time he had I think over 100
bills so this one was an oversight we
have not
put it in the in the any of the um
any parts of the budget so this is a way
to find out if Senate has more money
when it gets to them and they want to
spend it this this will be there but
it'll be at this point unfunded pretty
much but I would move uh Amendment 1185h
second
representative Petrie did you second yes
okay
further discussions on this this
representative hacken Phillips thank you
Mr chairman
know that under HP to division two has
expanded the eligibility of the
education Freedom accounts for uh
specifically I'm looking at page 13 of
the packet we looked at earlier today
um
where students who are who qualify for
free or reduced priced meals are now
also
they also that eligibility has expanded
the EFA program so I'm wondering how
these two bills will interact if if my
understanding of the expanded
eligibility for the efas was for a much
higher poverty level but here we're
seeing
the 300 I'm just wondering if you've
thought through that
interaction I'm just trying to set a a
limit on how high I can go the Senate
can address a lot of the details I this
this was a let's stop the bleeding
before it starts
attempt so it probably needs some more
work
it doesn't even have a fiscal note
because these these
amounts were unknown so before we could
anybody could place this in a budget
we'd have to know what what's the amount
of money likely to be and you know
what's the real reason for increasing it
so much and especially if this is going
to also another thing that it might
impact is all these things that we say
Okay free and reduced meals you get more
money in in your school budget if you
have more in free and reduced meals if
this is an attempt to to increase the
population that's getting that stipend
then this would be unaffordable if it's
used in that same way so this needs a
lot of work a lot of look so we put it
in there because it passed the house but
it's going to have to go on to the
Senate they're going to have to make
judgment on it at our point we we did
not have the money in in the budget and
we don't have even a fiscal note that we
could make a guess and also as I say the
effect on the other distributions under
free and reduced so
this is uh past the house we got to do
something with it we put it in but we
put this this line in there subject to
available funds so
it's there but it's not funded at this
point
further questions from committee members
shooting up
clerk will call a role on the amendment
1185h to House Bill 2 to adopt
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes
president McGuire yes
president
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Carol McGuire yes
representative kofo yes representative
Sweeney yes there's no cameras yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
original bucco yes Arizona grassy yes
representative you would yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes representative yes
representative haken Phillips
yes
it was going to Stringham
representative Wilder yes Mr chair of
the vote is 25-0 in favor
motion is adopted
you're done yep oh my God
okay
we have adopted uh division two's report
and we have put in some amendments
anything further from the committee
members on division two's report
seeing none will take about a five
minute break and then we'll go to
division three we'll see what we can get
done today on them we'll go probably
till about four o'clock
and we'll have more time on Wednesday
morning tomorrow we'll be busy with all
the bills that we have assigned we'll be
exacting
and I hope we get good attendance
and Edwards when you're ready
representative Edwards representative
Mooney and uh and Kevin Ripple will all
present division three uh thank you Mr
chair uh thank you members of the
finance committee uh just to get you
oriented uh there are going to be two
primary documents I'm going to talk off
of the pro the first document the
kickoff is labeled uh house finance
division three hb1 and hb2 proposed
amendments I'll go through the
Amendments first and then we'll go
through the longer sheet that's titled
detail change house finance versus
Governor division three category five
Because by the time we get through the
Amendments we'll have talked pretty much
about everything that's in the other
sheet as a summary
um first I'd like to just point out uh
how great I think that the the
Department of Health and Human Services
as well as the Veterans Home has
responded to our need for information
uh the the thoroughness of what they've
provided us the collegiality in which
it's been offered I want to thank
commissioner Weaver for that and Mr
Nathan white and uh and really all of
the division directors have spent all
kinds of time with us and of course none
of that would have been coordinated on
behalf of the the division and the in
the committee without Mr Kevin Ripple
and I maybe Mr Kane had a little bit to
do with it I wouldn't give him too much
credit but uh I'd really say Mr Ripple
has just been absolutely amazing
so with that
uh I'd like to give you sort of uh what
I I would consider the Strategic
imperative of what division three was
looking at this time around we were
looking at
um a a an hb17 from ways and means that
had a smaller amount of money in it than
what the governor spent
there's a talk of of a recession and
thankfully we have a nice rainy day fund
to you know kind of protect some of the
worst concerns from that but but then we
but then we also recognize that within
the state uh our one of our biggest
challenges kind of the unavoidable thing
in our in front of us is that the
emergency room boarding situation is
just unacceptable and it's essential
that we take whatever limited resources
we have we have limited resources and we
have unlimited wants and that's kind of
the first rule of Economics regardless
of where you go so we had to take our
limited resources to and to apply them
in a way in which you know I think we uh
have leveraged them fairly well and the
in the governor's budget
um what he proposed was a 3.1 percent
across the board Medicaid fix and I'm
not I'm not talking yet even to an
amendment I'm just doing an overview
what what he talked about was a 3.1
percent across the board Medicaid rate
increase and
um 3.1 percent if you take a look at the
ER boarding
situation uh which is I think in a
crisis almost third worldly
um we
really needed to address that and the
3.1 percent wasn't going to get us there
in his verbiage the governor told us
that if we wanted to try to Target
Medicaid reimbursement rates that that
we were encouraged to do so so in the
five or six months that the the
executive branch put together their
budget they did not provide us or offer
us a a methodology to do the medicated
Medicaid reimbursement targeted rate
increases
so
um so I'll talk some more about that
later but I just wanted to tee up the
idea that given that we were already
spending more than the governor or uh
well that we had less money than what
the governor had available to us and
that we had this major uh strategic
imperative that the governor hadn't
funded we were looking for Bill payers
we were looking for ways to save some
money and and particularly when we know
that we got these raises that aren't in
hb1 the 10 percent the two percent uh
respectively in the two years
um so so with that I I offer kind of as
a first example
Amendment
1196 hotel that's on page three
uh this is a often referred to as a back
of a budget cut
and it's identical to what's in the
current year or the current budget the
it it it
basically says that they are once they
get the their entire budget they have to
reduce it by 30.4 million
um by the end of the uh biennium I want
to take that money I want to put that
towards Medicaid reimbursement rates and
and given that inflation is so strong
there was some discussion about
increasing this 23.4 million to an
inflation-adjusted number we chose not
to do that we didn't want to put the
extra pressure on the department they
they handled this this current budget
year they can handle it next time I
believe and then we kept the number of
permanent
full-time employees at 3
they are authorized something in the
neighborhood of uh 3224 somewhere in
there
um and and this imposes a a ceiling of
three thousand and if I've done the math
right they've got about a 19 vacancy
rate which means they probably have at
least 500 positions they could fill
before hitting that three thousand so I
think the Practical effect of the 3000
is probably not particularly bad given
the uh the workforce shortages so so I
I'm spending so much time on 1196
because it sets a critical Cornerstone
to understanding the division three
strategy
uh we're not taking questions are we at
this point or are we why not I I don't
see one but my I have one over here okay
representative
walner
thank you
um speaking about the budget reduction
in the back of the uh budget
this originally came the the first one
we saw was a reduction in Staffing I
believe
this one is just a 23 million dollar
reduction of the of the um budget by the
general fund budget
don't we risk when we do that don't we
also risk losing federal funds because
so much of the department budget is
matched with federal funds so that 23
can easily become 40 million dollar loss
uh thank you for the question this is
the same debate that we had as we
formalized the current budget that we're
in
rather than expand and extend this we
decided to relent and hold fast with
where we were these are funds that the
department can choose to
save during the course of a two-year
period being smart enlightened managers
I would expect that they would take a
look at how they could reduce General
funding in a way to minimize or mitigate
any risk of federal loss of federal
revenue and again because some of these
monies that we budget are due to
Personnel anticipated that will never
hire there's probably already some room
built in there to where we weren't going
to spend the money anyways
isn't it isn't it true though that the
Department of Health and Human Services
like every other department of in the
state will also have a a lapse amount
that will be expected of them the
governor will allocate those those
lapses and require the Departments to
lapse them so the Department of Health
and Human Services will be looking at a
23 million dollar
reduction through this amendment plus
whatever they are allocated through the
lapse process
um to the extent that you have a point I
would say it's probably a fair and good
one but it's not within the purview of
division three division three is putting
this back of the budget
proposal together and any lapse might
come from somebody else it may come from
the total finance committee it might
come from the governor but I don't have
any controller or authority over that so
so again this is exactly what was in the
current budget that they're living
within and uh and and based on the
testimony it seems like they're doing
okay
she
EP
representative thank you Mr chair
I'm very confused you say that you want
them to have a back of the budget cut of
23 million if I'm reading your
spreadsheet correctly their total
general fund budget is 33 million
and that seems
no look I'm missing something yeah no
there are General funds are in like a
billion so I'll let Mr Ripple speak to
the specific number
yes I'd have to look up the general fund
figure in the budget but the figures on
the spreadsheet reflect the changes made
by division three not the total budget
thank you so follow up
follow-up yes please so is this a 20 cut
a two percent cut the he's going to find
the exact number but let's say it's a
billion dollars 23 million is 2.3
percent
and this is two per two point three
percent over the two years so it might
actually be you know one point something
and and done in a way in which they can
plan and anticipate and manage their
priorities
thank you I understand thank you for the
question horizontal sheet shows 2
billion or 200 million for the uh
for the biennium
so when the governor's recommended
budget the general funds Appropriations
are slightly over a billion dollars per
year
uh one per one percent and change
because this 23 million is over the two
years and it's over a billion a years
appropriated so we're talking about one
percent and loose change
and you just would hope that we had
management competence to handle a one
percent uh haircut
for the questions or comments
representative hack and Phillips
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm just trying to think
um and I can't pinpoint it so I'm
wondering representative are there any
other departments in our budget plans
that are also required to make these
cuts and caps as I said before you got
here and in the current budget this is
word for word what we're doing in the
current budget so I'd say there's uh
definitely precedent for this uh this
precedent I as I understand goes back uh
to a prior chairman I won't you know
from where
um so this is not newly invented
Human Services or are you speaking to
every Department
I'm only authorized at this point to
talk about division three which is the
Department of Health and Human Services
plus veterans the veterans home which is
not included in the uh this amendment
representative Earth for a question
just a comment uh related to what the
chairman was saying uh the Department of
Health and Human Services has known the
very large over budgeting
areas and one of the ones he mentioned
was the Staffing
um the the huge vacancies some of which
and I don't these not specifically
related even to covert or the current
issue with Staffing in general a lot of
these vacancies go back to 2018. so it
is a different department from the
others in the state and there's just
huge dollars that are being
um allocated to it
uh thank you for contributing that
um uh I appreciate it also I was born
out that that anything we save
we're trying to put into the Medicaid
reimbursement rate increase which is
intended to solve the number one
critical problem facing our health care
System right now which is the ER
boarding crisis so you know I I had
asked the executive branch for Bill
payers and and not seeing any in the
proposed budget this is a way to find 23
million that we can invest in our
patient care
representative Stringham for question
uh thank you for taking my question
um is it true that um you know some some
areas for example the developmentally
disabled budget that wouldn't be able to
be touched by this amendment while the
most likely place would be payroll where
there's a lot of uh vacancy right now
with a high likelihood of not being
filled so
um if it and if it was entirely from
payroll we'd be looking at uh seven to
eight percent out of this 19 current
vacancy uh being factored out
that would have been a good division
three uh conversation to have
um I I don't recall having that
conversation I would have asked the
department to prepare a more detailed
laydown of how the existing back of the
budget cut that they're already dealing
with where those dollars came from
specifically but I didn't anticipate the
question I might I apologize
I I do think last year that the her last
biennium
um the the
back of the budget was targeting payroll
entirely while this time
the department is being given more
flexibility if there is anything in
contracts or otherwise that could be
um
uh or would not be used that um they
could be taking it taken to account for
this as well so you know thank you for
your comment and I do recall that we did
amend this it's not exactly what the
current uh back of the budget is because
you're you're right we did put some more
flexibility in here I don't remember the
word usage we did exactly but the intent
was to uh to take some of the pain and
pressure off the department by making it
more flexible to get to the number yes
thank you thank you next question from
representative McGuire followed by
representative grassy thank you Mr
chairman twice you've used the phrase ER
boarding what is that
all right so I it's been in the news a
lot and I I apologize for assuming folks
may know what it is I should have
explained it better but we we have
um
some number of emergency rooms within
the state of New Hampshire right I'm
going to say 26 that's plus or minus a
few I think and each in each of those
facilities if somebody is brought to
their emergency room that's in need of
of
significant mental health or behavioral
health care if they're perceived to be a
danger to themselves or to others
then it's only appropriate for that
emergency room to discharge that patient
and do an appropriate Health Care
setting that can meet their their mental
or Behavioral Health needs
we have a critical shortage in beds to
receive all of those patients and since
the patients are coming in at a rate in
which it exceeds the ability to
discharge them you build this back up in
the emergency rooms and what that backup
does is since the hospitals are not
actually treating the patients within
their care requirements they cannot get
reimbursed so they are absorbing all of
the costs associated with maintaining
that patient in a minimal bed
environment in which it's essentially
you're keeping them safe and you're
feeding them and and that sort of thing
but they aren't getting care they're
simply being boarded I I have callously
used the word the term ER warehousing
because I I just find it outrageous that
New Hampshire finds itself in a
situation in which these patients are
being stacked up in the emergency rooms
without anywhere to go and so as we took
a look at the Medicaid
reimbursement rate hike opportunities my
first priority in that was to build
capacity on the discharge or on the well
for in the hospital it looks like the
discharge side but from the community it
looks like a you know bringing them into
the Community Care situation so
um so you'll we'll talk more about that
later but you know that's that's sort of
a nutshell of what the ER boarding issue
is does that answer your question
representative grassy thank you Mr
chairman
um I noticed you said that this back of
the budget cut that you're looking at
was something that we've done previously
so it's not something that's unusual but
I'll tell you one of the biggest
complaints I have from constituents is
the lack of the waiting time to get
services or with agencies
um
support agencies in our communities that
have extraordinary extraordinary
problems getting Services back from from
DHHS and that you know that there's just
the complaint they always hear is
there's just not enough Staffing and I'm
wondering if a cut like this could be
making the situation worse by you say
they can't fill positions well are they
holding positions open to meet this this
cut and not filling the positions that
they probably should be for positions
that they should probably should be
filling in order to provide adequate
services to our citizens and and the
agencies that serve our citizens
I I don't think they are as the short
answer and to get provided a little bit
more background as you know we have a
Workforce shortage uh across the state
and pretty much every area and
specifically within the healthcare
provider community and
um and so we're all chasing the same
scarce Personnel Resources uh so do I do
I think this imposition of the 3000 on
the head count is contributing to the
inability of DHHS to perform its Mission
I would say that the primary challenges
they have from a Personnel perspective
are really driven by the workforce
shortage throughout the state and to the
extent that if I were able to pick and
choose where people would go work I
would tend to want to prioritize the
Direct Care provision in DHHS they don't
actually do direct health care and so
where I'm seeing the crisis overall is
in the communities that need to be able
to receive the patients and provide
Hands-On or you know otherwise
therapeutic care to them and having that
employee in the community rather than in
Concord in office building between the
two I would have my priority being out
in the community treating patients
uh just just a point on this is that a
lot of times the problem of being able
to provide that service in the community
is they're not getting their
reimbursement so they're not getting the
necessary paperwork from DHHS I know
that if you take a look at some of the
situations that are going on in child
care I mean it takes forever to get
certification sometimes for people and
there's a lot of times it's paperwork
through DHHS before you can even hire
somebody or you can get somebody or you
can take a new person on into your
program if you can't get the paperwork
taken care of
okay so so you brought up two issues one
you started talking about reimbursements
that the reimbursements are too low and
so that's why I'm taking whatever money
we can find from the bill payers to help
increase the uh the reimbursement rates
later we haven't gotten to that part of
the conversation the theory is if we can
increase the reimbursements we can
increase the capacity we can improve
increase the ability to move patients
through the system so care should get
better to the extent that there's an
eligibility issue we've been we've got
money in here invested in continuing to
uh upgrade and improve the new height
system which is the the kind of the
universal eligibility checking system
Meanwhile we're spending something like
20.5 million dollars a year in
operations and maintenance for the
Medicaid management information system
so we're investing so much money in it
you were rash I'm rationalizing and
hoping uh that the the department is
right as if we invest in the I.T we can
get that efficiency we can get that
productivity out of the existing
Workforce so we're we're in a there is
no one answer to this we have attempted
to solve multiple problems and we're
trying to keep a balanced approach to do
the best overall we can with limited
resources and basically unlimited once
further from committee members
seeing none please proceed okay page two
that's a little joke uh no but literally
uh it's now page four
so
uh so this is
um a deletion on a peer-to-peer grief
support programming in this uh the
division voted in a very narrow way to
eliminate this uh it's it's basically
using fy23 money on the order of of 1.5
million and and this gave us an
opportunity to provide back to the
finance committee a total of uh this is
just 1.5 million a very small piece of
the 12.5 million that we estimated we
would not need from the FY 23 money
making it available elsewhere
on page five
this is
um
put in because when the budget was being
put together there was no known
end State on how the sununu replacement
Center would be brought together and so
this amendment is is basically a
vestigial organ to that and until we get
HP 49 through the system it it I
consider it still to be necessary
because it's directing that all federal
funds are all funds available that are
federal and discretionary should be used
to pay for the replacement system
um then on Page Six
uh we have a couple of items that that
sort of are in this in in the same vein
over the last many years a couple of
things have happened simultaneously that
we've tried to uh to deconflict and
clear up so that our books are more open
our behaviors are more transparent
they're both kind of related to the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs when that program was
instituted a a group of a large group of
stakeholders from around the state were
put together to take a look at the the
Damage Done by Alcohol and Other Drugs
and try to figure out what we can do to
prevent it and then treat it and to
follow up and so in order to fund that
effort outside of the budget and to
leave it to the stakeholders expertise
and their budgeting process we there was
a commitment to have five percent of the
the money that we spend through our
liquor stores
transferred over to the this commission
we've not been keeping that five percent
promise so uh so elsewhere uh we're
keeping that promise but what this
specific Amendment does is it takes uh
about 2.05 million dollars that would
have set a very bad precedent in my view
this was the first time that the
commission would have started to use
General funds
we don't want to simultaneously give
them the five percent of the liquor
money and then also be adding General
funds we should just do one or the other
and in this case giving them their five
percent which is a several year old
promise and then not doing some of these
things that the governor wanted to uh
wanted to do
um he wanted in this specific case
um to manage to administer administer uh
the recovery friendly workplace
initiative so it's not that I we're
opposed to the to that program but
funding it with General funds through
the commission through to the program is
a shell game that we shouldn't be
playing so the the division deleted this
on page seven
this is uh this is a similar
conversation uh you know whether the
program is the right program or not it
got caught up and and being part of a
shell game that went through the
governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug other drugs where we're funding it
with General funds and then we're
telling them that they have to go fund
the program that we want to that
violates the independence of that uh
prestigious stakeholder community and
their budgeting process so so this
deletion on this is not meant to
disparage the program but to ensure that
we're behaving an honest and transparent
way consistent with our past promises
on page
eight
um
this has been in several Budget Trailer
bills it basically says that the
department has the flexibility to uh to
fill unfunded positions as long as it
doesn't exceed the amount of money that
we appropriated for that Workforce and
in an effort to clean up hb2 instead of
having this thing pop up every two years
this amendment makes it permanent
on page nine
um this this was an appropriation for
the sununa Youth Center it started at
about 11 million dollars but because uh
there was uncertainty during the
governor's phase on what would happen
they had put it in hp2 and we directed
to have that uh operating money put
instead of an hb2 into hb1 so when we go
look at hb1 later you'll see the money
for that uh there's and and there will
be a little bit of discussion about that
uh later
then on page 10 and 11.
um this is for a new program that the
state has not officially started and to
the extent that the private sector has
started it it came from a request of the
hospital Association and the Nurses
Association The Nurses Association by
the way agrees with this amendment
supports this amendment uh and and what
what happened was uh in an effort to
establish a health care facility
workplace violence prevention program we
looked at that bill
um last year god it feels like two years
ago but we look I think we looked at it
last year there was no fiscal note even
though we impose new work requirements
and the most onerous was on the rule
making requirements of of uh of the
Department of Health and Human Services
but there were other ones as well
no fiscal note and then for some reason
even though we passed the law this just
failed to find its way into the
governor's budget so the the
commissioner has asked that that we
suspend the whole program
we don't want to suspend the whole
program we don't have to suspend the
whole program what what this amendment
does is it it suspends the state's
obligations on the program but uh
encourages and allows the uh the private
sector to go forward by establishing
their commission to look at uh Health
Care workplace violence and to identify
Trends they have a lot of work to stand
that commission up
that legislation
basically gives them the framework under
which to do it
um
it's a vital program I think but it just
we're just going to suspend the state
mandates now now if the state like the
Department of Health and Human Services
primarily but also the AG and labor if
they find that they have the bandwidth
the manpower to participate in the
program they can certainly do that the
this amendment allows them to do that so
so this is this was an attempt to find a
way to say yes without suspending the
whole program but still allowing it to
go forward
item 12 is is probably the most common
sensical amendment of all all this does
is uh it deletes a section saying you
can't admit people into the forensic
psychiatric hospital until the forensic
psychiatric hospital is built
okay so we deleted that because it was
the blinding flash of the obvious that
you can't do it anyway so why put it
into law
on on page 13 uh we took some Kerry Ford
funds uh aimed at supporting the
development the developmental Services
fund the acquired brain disorder
Services fund the In-Home Support
waivers we we kept that fully funded but
instead we pulled FY 23 money forward to
cover those expenses and you'll see that
later when we get into the hb1 item on
it's on page three but it this this
language is needed to enable hb1
the next one is Page 14. this
at first blush doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to somebody who hasn't been
focused on this for a while this this is
sort of the financial math related to
something called the county cap
the county cap is uh is a a process and
procedure under which the state and the
County nursing homes had long ago agreed
on how to split some costs what the our
attempt to do in the county cap is to
keep the counties contribution
towards keeping that agreement in the
two percent range last year was exactly
two percent uh this year or in this
budget We are continuing the exact same
amount of money so it's not going to be
exactly two percent because of inflation
and stuff but it's in that very same
ballpark we didn't want to make any
radical changes uh there
um this is a really great program if you
go and you talk to your county CFOs or
the nursing homes and you talk about the
county cap this provision directly saves
our residents property tax money in
Rockingham County last budget I was told
it saved them seven percentage points
and across the whole property uh the
county share the property tax so that's
a pretty good one I think a one question
thank you just a quick question vacation
I thought I heard you say that this
should increase in slight amounts with
inflation but I look at it and the
amounts were the year 23 24 and 25 are
the same I misunderstood something being
said could you clarify well I I think I
said it but I probably didn't say it
very well I I pointed out just as you
observed that uh the Cur the next budget
keeps the dollar amounts the same as the
second year of the current budget so
there's no increased money
and initially when we figured out how
much money to put we used the two
percent number but because this is a
second budget and the money hasn't moved
it's it's really not the two percent
anymore
yeah no problem I'm sure I could have
been more clear
okay
we're on 15.
okay so 15 is the is you know back to
your point uh uh representative grassy
you know how how can we be more
efficient how can we be more productive
well uh what the the department believes
is part of the answer to that is to
continuing to uh to maintain and operate
and upgrade the the Medicaid management
information system now this item
initially found its way in hb2 uh and so
that that really wasn't the right place
to put it because uh the dollar amount
was so big that I had assumed in the
previous budget that this was one-time
upgrade money and not an ongoing annual
operations cost and I was the full last
budget that said don't take this one
time upgrade money and put it into HP
one put it into hb2 and so they did what
I asked and this year when I was looking
at it and talking more about it it
became clear that this is just an
incredibly expensive operations and
maintenance and it belongs into hb1 so
so we moved it from hb2 to hb1 and in
order to fund it we used some FY 23
carryover money and you'll see the
detail on that on page one row 9 and 10
of the bigger Longer sheet
so now we're going to go to page 16. now
this is another to your your point of
how do we gain the productivity uh at
DHHS we're the new heights system is the
name of the integrated eligibility
system and so this is uh an audit of
that system to you know make sure that
it's complying with our requirements I
hope they're also looking at the
workflow to make sure that it's
efficient but anyways it's at least a
compliance audit we moved it it moved
this money instead of being FY 23
carryover we just funded it in FY 24.
then we're on page 17.
I would like to give
[Music]
am I is this the one I'm supposed to do
that on let me think for just a second
no not yet uh this this was
um okay there's something called
maintenance of effort
maintenance of effort is sort of uh if
you're playing poker it's kind of your
minimum anti or your minimum bid to even
get into the game with the feds in order
to get their Federal money we have to
meet a maintenance of effort level
um and if you take a look at the
programs where we have active expenses
associated with it if you take all the
general funds that we're planning to
spend in hb1 on on the TANF towards the
TANF where there's still a gap to our
minimum level of effort and so hb2
housed an extra three million dollars a
year so that we could make our minimum
level of effort and and what that did
for us is it bought us insurance so that
next time they calculate TANF they don't
penalize us and we get all the federal
money that we're eligible for
so looking at that three million dollars
a year we went back knowing that this
the estimate was six seven eight months
old and asked the department and this is
an example of Mr White stepping up for
us we asked them to do a new analysis to
see if the 3 million a year was still
the best estimate and he came back and
said that the department could be
comfortable with a 2.5 million dollar a
year amount so that that ended up
freeing a million dollars over the
um uh the biennium and you'll only see
this into hb2 but so that saves a little
bit of money now
thank you Mr chairman
when you add money to an area like this
does it somehow change the eligibility
requirements so so more people get money
or or the amount of money they receive
gets up a little higher how does
how does this money get spent so that we
meet the maintenance of effort this this
amendment does not change the
reimbursement rates for the TANF
eligible program but it does make money
available if there's greater levels of
utilization
so so if if there wasn't the demand for
this would we would we not meet
maintenance of effort or do you see what
I mean yes the answer to that is this is
the guarantee that we're going to make
the minimum payments necessary to
achieve the minimum uh the maintenance
of effort because failing to meet the
Min the maintenance of effort levels
causes substantial enough penalties and
a reduction in next budgets uh TANF
funding that we don't want that negative
event to happen so this is this is extra
money it's sort of like an insurance
policy do you want to add more to that
let me speak to that
um basically the need wasn't there we
wouldn't need the money the need is
there this is just make sure that we
have the money in general funds just in
case we need more General funds to match
what we're going to bring them down so
the need is there otherwise we wouldn't
care about the federal dollars this is
welfare this is the temporary assistance
in needy families
and in a bit we're gonna I
affectionately refer to them as the uh
the representative Waller amendments
where we spend more TANF money so she's
helping us spend all the money we can
put into the Tana funds so but we all
agreed
okay so page 18.
are there other questions no page 18 uh
this was a deletion of the Family
Resource Center funding of one million
dollars a year it wasn't that this is
not a good program it I wasn't clear
that there were adequate metrics to
measure exactly what these guys were
going to do for that extra million
dollars a year so we scraped it and we
put the 2 million over the biennium
towards Medicaid
reimbursement rates
Pages 19 through 21
okay so this is actually where I think
um the department did some really good
work together with in division three uh
and uh and a lot of people contributed
to it now now I think it's really good
work another point of view is it's not
very good work because we didn't put
enough money into it but so other than
the dollar amount we did some good work
what what we did was uh we listened to
the governor we listened to the
community and we were told that we ought
to increase the Medicaid reimbursement
rates
and we agreed with them we needed to do
that above the 3.1 percent that the
governor had requested and so then the
question is if you're going to increase
the rates which rates are you going to
increase and by how much
this amendment uh answers that question
if you look at it just the major
sections of it or on between lines 5
through 14 at 12 million a year that you
see there
keeps the governor's promise to give 3.1
percent across the board to everyone
one of the things that was surprising to
me was when the hospital Association
stepped forward and said
don't give us our share of the 3.1
percent
that was five million dollars a year had
we kept that 3.1 percent promise to the
hospitals instead of 12 million a year
this would have been 17 million a year
what that did was that freed up that 10
million dollars plus the other
funds that we were getting from saving
some money on some other programs to
spend across the board across all the
Medicaid
service providers
and we did that based on the work of the
community they came to us with a
spreadsheet of all the services and said
in order for us to basically
stay in business for the next couple of
years we really have to have sort of
this minimum amount of rate increase to
help us get through the next two years
so again unlimited wants and limited
resources we didn't have all the
resources to fully fund the community
request but we use their their format
and we used some of the information we
got from them so that we could allocate
what we could where we could with the
priority of solving the ER boarding
discharge issue
so I think this is good work
um because it establishes a framework
that had never existed that the
executive branch did I yeah I will but
it established a framework on exactly uh
a a methodology to uh allow the Senate
if they have a different amount of money
to invest this gives them a road map on
how to do that in a way that really will
address the community needs thanks that
was the point I wanted to make
representative Heath thank you and that
was a point I needed to hear as well
um
at the public hearing this is this is
the area that we heard loud and clear
from so many
um out in my community I hear it all the
time I hear it at the automatic meetings
that we have
now
what your defining for us
um this approach that you're taking will
mitigate to some extent the need to
raise the Medicaid rates but not to the
extent to which you'd like to so what
you've what I think I'm hearing is that
you're saying that you believe you CR
you've created a path to the Senate so
that the Senate then can pick up
and if they have additional funds can
further the work that you've started is
that what I heard
I I think you you could have heard it
that way I I would say it slightly
differently that it is a is it's an
establishment of a framework that can be
used by the Senate if they have less
money
they can use this methodology to figure
out where to pull money out if they have
more money they can use the same
framework to put money in it's a kind of
a bi-directional framework if you would
now to give you some order of magnitude
on what the blue team and the red team
were thinking this money is uh um it's
it's 24 million for the two years for
the 3.1 percent minus the hospital
request
plus
70.2 million dollars added that the
governor did not so we added 70.2
million dollars that that's that's a
nice chunk of change
um what was I I think the ballpark that
um our our friends across the aisle
wanted in the division was on the order
200 million or or maybe a little more I
don't know but they can speak for
themselves but be somewhere between 70
and 200 million is the the different of
opinion and when you look at 130 million
dollar difference of opinion and you go
back and you look at these some of these
little players in here that help
contribute to to our our bill payers it
it it's not it's not a whole lot of
money and we're putting it into
something that I think is going to be
critical to the state in the next two
years
go ahead and representative Mooney you
had a comment thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr chair I just want to add to
that that with regards to this amendment
as a member of division three I'm quite
proud that we formatted it like this and
I want to give a special shout out to
representative Stringham who introduced
this format never before has this been
laid out so clear and so specific as it
does in this amendment so representative
Stringham did fantastic work with his
team in terms of getting us this format
that we could work off of thank you
well in representative verf and
representative hole then used a very
similar format and and and came up with
different numbers in a way in which
there's a methodology that can be
explained an algorithm to allocate money
that if you change out the amount that
to put in the algorithm will generate
the money invested so it I I don't know
it's I think it's good work for a group
that aren't professionals
yes thank you
so what this represents what we're
looking at here is that about half
of what um
the Medicaid providers said they felt
they needed
because this all most of this amendment
really came from the work of the
provider Community as a coalition they
got together
um they had a number of some providers
needed a percentage increase some
providers needed a daily rate income I
mean it was it was a variety of ways
that they needed to be reimbursed and
these are really providers who as you
heard of the at the hearing they're very
fragile they are really some of them are
if we lose them it will be debt very
detrimental to New Hampshire
I mean the the people who do the
community
work with families where if an elderly
family member stays at home instead of
going into the nursing home they can do
that work for
twenty thousand dollars a year to keep
someone in their own home on an average
whereas if they go into a nursing home
it's closer to hundreds of thousands of
dollars
so
these are the providers that really we
really need to be sure they're in good
shape this is half of what they told us
they need we've had 14 percent inflation
over the last couple of years they
haven't had a rate increase since two
years ago and some of the providers
hadn't had a rate increase for many
years before that so these providers are
really really this they are our safety
net to keep people out of nursing homes
people with developmental disabilities
in higher end services and this is
really where we need to focus and I
think
providing them with
let a lot less than they need providing
them with fifty percent less than they
feel like they need
um
could end up being a real problem for
the state and for thousands of people
that they serve
to so if I could I agree with everything
but the last sentence or two of what by
the representative just said and I I
what I what I have attempted to say is
we have a framework with an algorithm if
we had more money we could put it in
there and it'd just be a math problem uh
so so not knowing how much money we
would have as a finance committee we we
took a best shot at keeping division
three within some guard rails so that we
could come to an event like this and and
if there were extra money I I'd
certainly be open to putting it into
this program but
um so that's where we're at
difference between you know 90
94.2 million on our side and and maybe
you know 20 224 on the other any number
in between there is you know a number
representative
no just that my seat mate here
was informing me of how much nursing
home care cost and
um
yeah well we found out on our Merrimack
County budget it's it's something like
400 000
a resident for our Merrimack County home
I mean it's just an absolute incredible
amount of money
okay represent Sweeney for a question
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you to the chair and vice chair division
three this is actually a genuine
question that I do not know the answer
to
um providers that are benefiting from
this the Medicaid rate reimbursement
schedule the program especially the the
new one that's been laid out in this
amendment to hp2
are they allowed
individually as individual units or
groups to go to the fiscal committee or
to the executive Council to get funding
after the budget is adopted in a
emergency need basis is that an
allowable application or are they
what we do in the budget is is they're
locked in for two years okay so
generally as I understand it uh people
can go to the fiscal committee under two
scenarios uh and and in both scenarios
it's a it's the state doing it in
scenario one uh there's Federal funding
funding that's been made available and
we have to take a look at the guidelines
and the money and figure out if that's
consistent with the programs we want to
run then the other is when the
department will come to us and say
there's a transfer that I need to do
that exceeds the The Authority that I
already have so and both in those
instances it's the state your question
is can the providers come to us to ask
for more money they can certainly no not
through the fiscal committee but they
can go to you know Mr lippman in the
department say hey you got to help us
and you know maybe depending on the
flexibility we've given them we may be
able to do something in the next
Amendment so cycle of the MCO contracts
to to get the money to them but through
the mcos but not no direct payments
representative Stringham yeah and just
in terms of of the numbers that the
process uh revealed that revealed
um uh you know the first year we we
figured on average it would take about a
quarter to update any Medicaid rates so
the Medicaid uh rate increases actually
or three quarters the first year the
second uh as there would be the second
year of the biennium and uh so uh the
total numbers came out to about 175
million or you know maybe uh 80 million
or so 85 million over uh what came out
of of our department
uh this is probably even even with the
hospitals kicking in their piece uh this
isn't keeping up even with inflation and
there was already terrific provider
shortages on certain areas you know if
you can't hire somebody to come in and
take care of somebody for twelve dollars
an hour and that's the rate uh it you
know the rate the rate uh is the work
isn't going to get done unless unless
it's by relative or something else so
um I appreciate the hard work that was
done and the prioritization on all these
uh but it is still as uh representative
Edwards indicated uh probably not enough
to keep keep the system from
um further degrading rather than getting
close to being back on track thank you
I I I'd agree with everything you said I
I just would point out that that this
amendment at least does 60 million more
than the governor proposed so
uh so I don't think any division created
their own 60 million dollar expenditure
uh division three did that yeah
so uh should I go on Mr chair
okay
um
so page 22.
we uh okay the governor and we agree
that we have an issue with not enough
beds to discharge people out of the ERS
into some sort of a follow-on care we
agree to that so he had three hb2 items
that essentially created
I'm going to use the term unfunded
mandate because although it's not the
correct constitutional term in this
context it's the same concept and that
is that he was directing
percentages of of beds that needed to be
built or numbers of beds rather that
needed to be built as a drf designated
receiving facilities and we we weren't
giving them any money to do it we were
telling them to the hospitals to do it
anyways even though we know they have
Workforce shortages and in order to
staff a bed they have to take staff from
somebody else somewhere else and put it
into the drf and and and that's all
being done in a way in which it's a
top-down command driven uh government
edict and so it just didn't seem like
the right way to build the capacity that
is really needed out there we agree on
the goal certainly didn't agree on the
technique
so we struck those three requests
um item or page 23
this is uh the first of two
representative walner
amendments this was a good one
she recognized that there we have a
federal reserve of TANF money it's
approximately 67 million so she she I
didn't she identified that she said can
we can we go ahead and have some of that
TANF money fund unemployment related
child care services
which are vital to rebuilding the
workforce and to avoid a wait list so
was this the one that was seven million
or 2.4 million I didn't write that down
[Music]
um
but
we didn't have a cost
okay
then the the next one uh also addresses
a Workforce issue by adjusting the child
care eligibility up and I'm I forget the
percentage it's currently I think 60 65
60 we wanted to raise it to 85 percent
and then we stuck with an 85 percent of
the state availability of services
number instead of converting it to the
federal poverty levels to be consistent
across our statutes we talked about
changing to an FPL instead of this but
we decided to keep it at the 85 percent
Benchmark because the dollar amount
between it and 300 percent was you know
de minimis uh so so and since this
language matches the federal language we
thought it might be easier and to be
consistent with the federal law so this
is a Workforce issue should make a
access to child care in theory a little
bit easier because more people will be
qualified for it
um then on page 25
this was uh you know our way to say uh
can we adjust the rates at which uh the
child care gets reimbursed we
um said that there's a couple of
different ways that you could do a rate
adjustment one is to take a look at
something called the true cost of care
mechanism then the other is to take the
75th percentile of a market rate survey
we didn't designate which of those two
ways the department could choose but we
gave them the option and said
essentially that's going to raise the
reimbursement rates for child care
presumably we're going to find Workforce
to actually take the higher salaries
the item on 26 and 27 is related to the
prescription drug affordability board
the pdab
um this board the chairman of division
one and I uh took interest in from
January of last year when a item came
before the fiscal committee asking for
funding and so we started to take a look
at the statute and the statute basically
creates the most autonomous most
powerful
little entity in the state so what this
amendment does is it and it also does it
in a way in which a lot of what they do
is redundant with other departments so
what we said was let's go ahead and keep
the program let's scale it back a little
bit uh let's make sure that we take a
look at the redundancy issues across the
Departments within the state government
and and oh by the way gel car looked at
what was called a fee schedule in the
pdab statute as they were doing rule
making and unanimously determined that
the it was probably an unconstitutional
tax and then they specifically said you
know this has to be relooked by the
legislature because the way of raising
revenue is is probably
inappropriate so there were two
amendments both amendments agreed that
what we ought to be doing is instead of
having them have this unconstitutional
tax Authority that we should instead
allocate General funds to them that
solved the unconstitutional issue of the
the tax also it it made sure that this
this group was a little more accountable
to the an elected body so so that's what
the pdab amendment does there's a lot of
detail in there
um
then online uh or excuse me Pages
question
Carol McGuire yes thank you Mr chair uh
is this amendment compatible with the
two or three bills and commerce dealing
with the prescription drug affordability
board
I'll say yes but uh the the yes part is
to make sure you're listening to the
rest of it but uh representative
leishman and I uh co-sponsor jointly
sponsored both those bills that went to
Commerce this this this uh bill in in
hb2 that's in here is consistent uh I
think pretty much line for line with
what uh the the current amendment is in
Commerce Commerce is holding at 10 10.
so this
unfortunately I I had asked the chairman
to just get it on the floor and let's
see where it stands
um and it's still it's going to be
retained by the committee
but yes remember the word yes
thank you
further questions from committee members
seeing none
please proceed
okay so 28 because you know we love
controversy
we went ahead and took the sentence
version of Medicaid expansion and based
on the the the bill that they passed I
don't remember if it was 22 to 2 or 24
to nothing they they they passed it on
an extremely strong vote and we're going
to be seeing it as a bill later but
um we've we went ahead and put it into
hb2
A
administrative thing that we did was we
required that any money that goes to pay
for the Medicaid expansion Bill be put
into the budget instead of doing this
you know off the books sleight of hand
kind of thing that I think we've been
doing
um it just makes it open makes it
transparent it's good government
and because this part of the Medicaid
Program is reimbursed by the federal
government at extremely high rates I
think it may be as high as 90 percent
right now instead of the typical 60
percent and and we know that it's going
to decline at some point to 88 percent
but we know that the feds are not going
to keep this commitment forever to be
paying on the order of 90 percent so
what what we did in here was we put a a
two-year
Sunset date on our version this the
Senate said make it permanent
our division said make it two years
I I want to put I want to put two years
into context for you
this this is the contract for
a Managed Care Organization this this
represents you know five six hundred
hours of man hours uh to put together uh
it's it's put together at the state
level by our most senior people in the
department so it's a very expensive
Manpower uh and this is typically one
contract for five years
if we do it this way with two years it's
one contract that by the time it gets
done is only going to be good for a year
so so under the two-year provision in
here we're going to be doing one of
these essentially every year or every
other year spending the Manpower there
there is some good government thought
that that instead of two years it could
be four years it could be six years but
that's that's a discussion this
amendment says two years
representative waller for a question
so I think the department told us how
how much time and thought has to go into
developing these contracts and
um five years
seem to be what the standard was for
doing this kind of a very involved piece
of work
um
I guess the other part about this whole
thing is that there was a commission and
on the commission that studied the
Medicaid expansion for the past
couple of years there were several
meetings at the end of it the commission
members
agreed that this program should continue
permanently
and for many of us that were on it we
signed a document saying that we agreed
to the commission report the commission
report is available for anyone who wants
to see it
so I think that there has been a lot of
thought and a lot of work done
around Medicaid expanded expanded
Medicaid and the five-year taking it to
the five years and then it makes a lot
taking it permanently and not just to a
two-year or a five-year
Sunset so I hope that we can
continue to work on this issue as it
goes forth and we also are getting the
bill is has passed the Senate and will
be coming to us so there will be
hearings and a lot of input here around
this I don't even feel that I personally
don't even feel this section is
necessary
um thank you for that and I was on that
commission with you and somebody heard
me say that the commission recommended
permanent and I was told that they just
reviewed the text and we were
ambivalent on the length of time we said
that the legis something of the effect
that the legislature
ought to consider whether or not to make
it permanent I don't think our
commission technically said that but
everything else you you said I I
basically agree with
um if if instead of two years we said
six years what would what would happen
would be it would take about a year for
the current contracts there are three of
them so we have three mcos it would take
about a year for those to expire and
then uh and in that time we'd get these
contracts in place and these want to be
five-year contracts so if you're just
looking at it from a business analyst
perspective there's a strong
six-year
timeline that might be considered
but we want to so
um questions from
representativelorski thank you
thank you representative for taking my
question didn't we hear also that um
putting out the contract or the bid for
a two-year contract
was not going to attract the number of
vendors and interests would not be able
to attract a more affordable contract
for us because they they want to bid for
a longer term five-year or longer that
in the end this would probably be a
significant additional cost on the state
your memory of the testimony and mine
are the same but because the chairman
said I have to finish at four o'clock or
something bad happens I am just pushing
through it you don't have to finish at
four well I said we'd likely take a
break oh okay good good thanks we'll
have I just got a note that uh from I
guess it's from the LBA that since
tomorrow we've although we have 26 bills
to exec I think 16 of them are retained
so I don't expect a lot of discussion on
retained bills so we may have time to go
into division three and and in the in
the later part of the day after we
finished with all the executing so we'll
plan and also I wanted to announce for
any other public that's here to listen
yes I had told you earlier that we've
spent all day tomorrow on executing but
now that I look at the number that are
on retain I have a different opinion so
there will be time left to I hadn't been
able to see how many were recommend was
retained until today so there will be
time for you tomorrow
so all right uh thank you sir So
speaking of retaining bills uh Pages 32
and 33 represent House Bill 565 that uh
that uh division three recommends be
retained uh this was sponsored by
representative Megan Murray uh what it
does is it takes postpartum care under
Medicaid and extends it from three
months of Eligibility to 12 months we
had testimony from Dr Ballard the chief
medical officer at DHHS that the
12-month standard is kind of the is
clinically appropriate and so this is uh
this is two hundred thousand dollars
this was FY 24 only
and Mr Ripple is this the one where I
was supposed to mention that we need to
probably consider an amendment to make
this uh non-lapsing so that any money we
appropriate is good for fy25 as well
if the committee wanted us to change
this from to for the biennium ending
June 30th 2025 instead of the fiscal
year ending June 30th 2024 that's
something we could do as uh that's how
spill two was put together
and Mr chair I apologize I I don't know
how this got by division three but it
did and I think division three my guess
is that we'd all probably support that
for the most part
you want to change distance rather than
one year to a two year yes sir without
changing the dollar amount
I I I think that was just an oversight
apologies
okay so Mr Ripple has is the ability to
do that
okay
representative thank you I just wanted
to clarify do we know if that amount was
budgeted for the two years and it's just
a technical error in the writing or if
we need that amount for each year
in the hurried huddle in between changes
uh there was a quick agreement the 200
000 was the right amount amongst the
legislators without me talking to the
LBA or to the department but my
understanding is two hundred thousand
for the two years was acceptable
and that we just need to make it
non-lapsing
and right now Mr Ripple is taking a look
or I think whether or not it's it ought
to be 400 000 or should cap to 200.
do you have a quick one Mr White
you don't know
all right
well I don't know what the intent was of
the sponsor or of the policy committee
that the bill came out of
um
if you look at the fiscal note it's it
reflects a higher figure per year it
reflects
an estimated cost of between three
hundred thousand to one million per
fiscal year
so I I don't want to do budgeting on the
Fly we had an agreement that we would
just make it non-lapsing
so since we can only do one Amendment
I'd I'd suggest doing that
okay
represent or on pages 34 36
this is another retained bill this is a
HB 91 this is a bill that the house
voted on we voted on it twice now by the
way we voted on the almost exactly the
same bill in the previous term this
would already be law but it was taken
hostage in a committee a conference and
and was killed as part of a failed
negotiation but but HB 91 establishes a
couple of requirements on the Department
of Health and Human Services to form a
privacy Council that's consistent with
corporate standards it also establishes
a risk mitigation approach and it funds
a couple of Specialists that have the
training and somehow after all this time
this is another one that got by me got
by us but I'll I'll take full
responsibility on line 24 it says it's
300 thousand dollars for the fiscal year
ending in 2024 this should have been
non-lapsing and this one I know is meant
to be three hundred thousand per term so
I I would ask Mr Ripple to prepare an
amendment for us to vote on you know
tomorrow that makes it three hundred
thousand a year for two years each I
think in this case and the previous case
this is something you could do verbally
without a new amendment being presented
to you
I I I don't know I defer to the chairman
on those I think those were the only two
where we had this issue right
do you want to vote on on the going from
uh 300
000 one year for 300 000 two years
I think if
um
I think this change is uncontroversial
enough that we could
we meaning the LBA could make this
change as a technical change if the
committee opts to adopt this amendment
package so I don't think you need to
take another vote on this item
specifically
you don't think we need to have a vote
now about the previous one
it's if you would like to take a vote by
all means do but I think this item is
technical enough in nature that it's
something that we could just do on your
on the committee's behalf
ladies and gentlemen at the end of this
at this end of this meeting I will be
making a
an announcement that I hereby authorize
the LBA to make any Technical and
mechanical changes necessary to reflect
the intent of the committee
so if that's acceptable to everybody
that's what I will make at the end of
this and then that allows them
especially on divisions one and two to
go in and make anything that's been
brought up that needs to be corrected
and then at the end of the final at the
final end of division three I'll make
that same announcement so they can begin
working on Technical and mechanical uh
Corrections that have been identified so
without objection
that's the way they will proceed is
there any objection to that
seeing none that's how we will proceed
oh should I continue with the next item
page 37
this was another retained Bill sponsored
by a representative Joe Shapiro it's
it's formerly known as House Bill 282
it
correctly identified 336 thousand
dollars is being needed allocated in FY
24 and just said it was going to be
non-lapsing this will be used
to for the children and pregnant women
in Medicaid and Chip which is otherwise
known as the children's health insurance
program
okay on page
this was formerly known as House Bill
we've recommended retaining and this is
related to
the water situation in Merrimack this
bill is the the God child of
Representative Mooney do you want to say
anything on this representative Mooney
thank Mr chairman just to remind
everyone that Merrimack is the location
of the worst pfas contamination in the
country
this bill would authorize phase three of
a feasibility study on the increased
amount of kidney cancers in the
Merrimack the town of Merrimack region
only twice twice in 10 years has a
feasibility study been recommended to go
from phase two to phase three because of
the severity of the circumstance and
this is one of those instances so with
that I would like to actually mention
representative Nancy Murphy who was the
sponsor Prime of House Bill 614 and that
exact language to have that feasibility
study go from phase two to three it will
be in House Bill 2 soon I hope with your
support thank you
can you describe what phase three might
entail
as I understand it Faith three is a more
concentrated effort on the community in
order to make the feasibility study
known better and to communicate with
those who have been affected or think
they may have been affected in order to
do a deeper study into the increase in
cancer numbers so it likely will be the
first time there'll be a human study all
the all the reports I read are all
rodent studies and they don't really get
into humans they just say we think this
we think that based upon the rodent
study so this would be the first time
perhaps that we'll have a human study
and I I think we all know it but still
worth mentioning this past the house
policy Committee in the House vote so
um
all right uh moving on to page 39 the
last in the package
um the very first hearing
of division three where we heard that to
bring a kid into the sununu center
required a strip search
we all acted as one to say that's
unacceptable is there an alternative and
the department was ready with an
alternative pretty quickly where they
can put a full body scanner in there and
allow the intake of the detainee uh with
more dignity than a first if than a
strip search upon you know first
greeting and given the importance of a
trauma-informed therapeutic based Care
Center those body scanners more
appropriate
so what we did
because this was a the estimate was
three hundred thousand so we put a not
to exceed 325 000 we did it with the
expectation that the service costs would
be included in that initial contract so
we'd get through the fiscal year at
least if not more
the department agreed to eat that money
out of the budget that the governor had
already approved
we then also reduce their budget a
million dollars a year because they had
budgeted overtime
and in order to help them meet the
commitment to get the body scanner and
to get to keep the Personnel on site
that are needed and other expenses
operate for the next two years we
granted them a great deal of transfer
Authority so that they can manage the
money that we do give them and so with
that flexibility uh the department was
was okay at this point with the proposal
and so Sir with that I'm done with the
thick package and the short package all
of these are basically hb2 references
it's approaching four o'clock I'll I'll
do what you'd like
Here's my thought since we have a couple
of substitute people with us today who
have heard all this discussion and they
may not be with us tomorrow
if we go to do your hb1 piece tomorrow
when we have different people
then I would
unusual to the first two divisions I
would like to make a separate vote for
your presentation on hp2 if there's no
objection since as I said we have some
substitutes and I want to make sure that
the people who have heard the discussion
are the people who vote so
I'll ask the the clerk to the motion
will be to accept the hb2 Amendments
from division three that have been
briefed thus far
and
I'll say the emotions made by
representative Edwards to be seconded by
representative Mooney and is there any
further discussion or questions on that
process
seeing none representative Wallner well
even though I have spent the last
several months here working on the
division three
amendments and the presentation
I am going to vote no I still feel that
the Medicaid reimbursement rates are too
important to not fund them at a higher
level so that we don't we don't
take the chance of losing any of these
really important providers and I'm also
very concerned about
um the Medicaid
expansion that's in this in-house Bill
too I think is completely unnecessary to
have it there thank you
further discussion
representative kofault
I'm sorry that's ringham's
thank you um I did I wanted to mention
that I deeply appreciate the input from
all my all uh the division
Representatives uh with the intelligence
hard work and creativity
particularly grateful for the chair
co-chair and Mr Ripple uh and I
appreciate the hard work and diligence
to prioritize and fund the services
which is some Medicaid rates and um
I like
um
like representative walner do come down
that we're too far short for me to be
able to vote for this amendment at this
time because of the um uh the potential
risk to the Medicaid system at this
level of funding but
um I acknowledge the great work that was
done and uh hope that it can continue to
progress from here thank you
further from committee members
seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the motion to accept the hb2
um presentation from division three
as amended by the division
Circle call the roll thank you Mr
chairman
representative erf yes president McGuire
yes representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Carol McGuire you
represent cofo yes representative
Sweeney yes representative cambrose yes
representative papovichi Mahler yes
Representative walner no
Representative norgren no
representative leishman yes
representative buco
yes
president grassy no
Rosanna Hewitt um
version of Heath no
representative Murray no version of evil
no
Representative no
representative haken Phillips
no
representative Stringham nope
version of Weiler
Mr chairman the vote is 15 to 10 in
affirmative
emotion is adopted and again I will make
the authorization
to LBA to make any Technical and
mechanical changes necessary to reflect
the intent of the committee on this
piece we'll do the final one when we
brief on hb1 tomorrow after the exec
session so any of you that are
interested that I told earlier would
just be doing exact session no we will
be returning to hb1 as amended by
division three after we work on the
exact session for all the bills
it may be somewhere in the afternoon
representative Edwards uh Mr chair I I
think I'm aware of another amendment
that may be brought forward also typical
or like he did with the other divisions
after the vote we also talked about
other amendments and we may have at
least one of those I will say that we
are open to amendments to hp2 that may
come tomorrow when we get back to
division three's briefing
so I'd like to see all the division
chairs in my office when we want to be
complete here
thank you
and uh we'll we'll go on recess for
today and come back tomorrow at 10 to
begin the exact session on the I think
it's 26 bills thank you all for your
attendance thank you all for your
consultation
good night
foreign